s'il fab d'ici quelques instants ne
jouez le rôle à jouer car si on attends
attends attends une petite seconde ça va
arriver
ces caresses et caruana 4 c'est beau et
j'ai tout cas joué le 4 way une poignée
de titres grünfeld aujourd'hui alors
est-ce que great choc va faire ce que je
crains depuis un long moment c'est à
dire retournez fable dans le pion
empoisonné ah oui alors attendez ses
droits mais peut faire kf3 encore ou des
4es dame prend aussi fait des cats et la
france et qui veut faire annuler en
faire des coeurs demain il va faire les
quatre dames prendre mais il peut faire
d'amd de b3 tout simple très intéressant
ouais mais ça a été un aliment analysé
badauds futé mais ça et qui n'ont
encaissé six jeux 6 mai revois alors
l'idée dont on parlait avec fab
ici c'était de jouer car lycées 6 dames
d2 puis joue avec b3 four b2 gros qu'on
avait vu une très jolie partie fab de
carlson contre voight hasek
oui moi je suis aguerrie père mal réagi
et fait déglinguer alors c'est pas
facile de proposer un peu désolé boychuk
ce n'était pas si simple puisque c'est
être complètement nouveau et surprenant
non non c'est pas mal mais je les jouais
une fourchette entre morzine au magazine
têtu avait battu tu as 12 ans tué mans
fort que moi
irish qui se lèvent déjà sportif le fait
un truc de 2,15 à fait j'ai ici ce
week-end mais elle a été confrontée à
cette ouverture quelquefois par le passé
ouais ouais on trouvait un conte ricard
ou par exemple en longues ou en rapide
fab
tu te rappelles pas rapide je pense
plutôt rapide mais ouais c'est un peu la
mode mois en fait c'est pas bête pour
les noirs pour les blancs système en
gros tu peux plus trop jouer tes 5t
système classique basse sur envoi le
pion g6 on va jouer on va aller simple
vers avoir assez loin du coup à foisches
six normales des f4 tendent alors tu
provoques f4 ou juste est content
d'avoir en fourrage 6 d'un dut provoque
tu provoques et puis après tu pourras
mettre une pression de substrats de5 qui
peuvent partir on passe trop vite mais
ça peut arriver bon alors que rich ou
qui joue quoi ils jouent le gain il joue
pas le lien qu est-ce que restant de son
sentiment la prairie pour moi je joue
une partie compliquée d'accord en fait
l'idée devait d'amd de b3 sais que c'est
pas ultra mainstream théorique et sa
déposition qui joue et c'est pas si
simple pour les noirs mais ni pour les
moeurs va c'est compliqué quoi c'est
plutôt une bonne nouvelle ça ouais c'est
une partie en fait et donc l'idée se
fiant de kétou sais que tu veux tu as du
mal à attaquer car tu as tu fait à cinq
bombes h au pire je te fais à 4 et puis
on en parle plus quoi donc
en fait tu auras le roi du grand bien
bien comme il faut à l'abri mais le faux
âge 6 silva est bien placé parce que
face aux pions la dame le roi il ya tout
le monde finale de la bouffe on va dire
tu peux lui balancer du 1,5 tandis
qu'ayyash 5 qui peut arriver souvent
doit faire un petit fou j'ai quatre
intermédiaires et puis le jour où tu as
eu 5 ta la casse des cas depuis colin
cavalli dessus donc - oui en tout cas
mon maximum connaît c'est clair donc la
clé c'est le pion aux 5
normalement c'est ça l'idée n'est pas si
tu es fou assistant ferro cinq sa perte
tout son sens
tout cas maxime réfléchi great choc qui
se lève bon c'est clair qu'il s'est
préparé à jouer ça un gris tchouk on
connaît on connaît sacha c1 c'est un
requin
non mais ça n'allait pas un gentil
garçon sacha cetim requins non monsieur
il va fort que maxime répondants requins
aussi exactement mais après je sais pas
s'il a plusieurs et fils a récemment
s'il a bien évité ces fichiers façon il
a pu viser un on sait que maxime va
jouer à fond
du côté grec il a pu réviser maximos il
a dû réviser ses fichiers la force et
non ce matin mais globalement c'est pas
chier tu sais que ça peut arriver mais
ok je sois au top c'est une partie en
fait j'aurais plus penser à une
situation à peu donné à moi aussi
j'allais dire trois heures de nage d'or
sous contrôle un peu le foot est roi
comme ça non mais je te dis que great
choc pour lui ben voilà il a une chance
sur mille six cent de faire 4 sur 4 6 et
4 sur 4 gagnent les candidats il vit son
rêve jusqu'au bout il veut mourir les
armes à la main et donc le morceau que
m'envoyaient vlad tout à l'heure ce que
valent en réalité je n'ai pas dit
maintenant que ça commence et je peux le
dire mais v'là de m'envoyer un lien une
chanson sûr sur youtube et j'ai dit à ma
femme quand j'ai dès que j'ai allumé la
chanson comme je connais la chanson puis
c'est un truc qu'on écoutait avec la ddt
je vis aujourd'hui gris tube va jouer
enfin j'ai dit ouais c'est là d'un faux
il envoie cette chanson c'est que
critique va envoyer et tu vois j'ai bien
lu le message de la il a avec un tel jeu
peut envoyer des messages paraît il
comprendra tu sais à mur tu as jamais
envoyé ça il n'aurait pas pu connecter
il croque la vie dans sa voiture le
loisir avec intel comme kevin tu envoies
cette chanson qui sait tout de suite de
quoi ça parle tout de suite
et tu sais le plus drôle c'est que vlad
est vraiment capable de dire ça genre
des fois en troll mais genre ça il est
vraiment capable de liens à kiev je peux
faire tu sais
c'est pas moi je sais plus j'ai trois le
tio2 pour défendre les pions ouais mais
écoute on va voir je ne sais pas c'est
déjà compliqué c'est déjà peut-être plus
ou moins nouveau d'ailleurs déjà deux
chaises base et studieux pour cela faut
quoi on l'a japon marrant quand même
sept jours agités sûr j'étais vraiment
sûr sûr j'étais vraiment sur de fins je
savais de quoi ça parle et je savais
vraiment de quoi ça parlait donc tu peux
me train un échiquier ce que oui mais
bon on va gagner un peu de temps et bien
sûr je vais tout de suite te dire ouais
je dois je penser très rare
toutefois ces nouveautés qu'il ya eu des
nouveautés ne souffre pas faut parfois
faire qu'une fois le montrer à qui voit
toutefois mal acquis a lieu de
nouveautés ouais c'est ça c'était j'ai
trois mas ont le même choix c'est que ça
bon mais ça transpose partagez diffusez
joué par maria hockey ouais pas
s'appliquer au hasard ouais bah
nouveautés budget juke
après je pense pas que ça aura m
spécialement en cause la variante mais
c'est juste frais et c'est complètement
dans les dettes d'amd de b3 dont vous
jouez un truc qui fight avec on se
débrouille sur l'échiquier on joue on
maigrit tu qu'il ya quand même eu un
petit peu analysé un ânon mais c'est
surtout d'analyser parce que là bien sûr
tu as un coût qui devient pour les noirs
c'est de faire bouger 4 et tu dis tiens
je te gaver les menaces pour un f4
salaires après saint papy si les blancs
font gt3 pour défendre la matière je te
fait froid g4 a priori c'est un coup tu
peux te dire pourquoi pas tu peux dire
pourquoi pas froid bien tu prends
efficace on prend des six je sais pas si
je crois du fou c'est ça l'idée moi je
sais pas de thunes qualité tu viens de
mettre les salisiens est ptet le four b2
qui votent rien n'était ou face à ça
c'est sûr qu'il analysa fond mais c'est
ça m'est donc déjà purgé 4 faut calculer
un autre coup c'est peut-être cavaliers
g4 une menace pour chatons laraque temps
je crois que maxime a joué il faut aussi
très joué faut aussi très vite il a
toujours su assez très possible qu'il
ait toujours su parce que comme on le
disait je sais plus quel jour en fait
une nouveauté officielle s'est pas
spécialement une nouveauté dans les
fichiers des joueurs mais
il avait très vite j'aurais conservé kg
4 ça donne il a il a joué beaucoup trop
vite pour quelqu'un qui connaît pas
parce que la pollution était vraiment
complet est vraiment complexe il ya
beaucoup de choix maxime qui répond en
moins de deux millions kotok alors après
il peut y avoir quand même une petite
chose contre gries tchouk sais que ça
peut ne pas être débile de jouer vite et
de le faire de lui faire jouer des
positions comme ça où il a beaucoup de
choix et qui se met mal autant s'il
adore elle ça c'est une très bonne
stratégie pour battre great choc c'est
un peu un counter c'est de lui laisser
une position compliquée où il ya
beaucoup de coups candidats du coup il
ya oui quel coup choisir et il se met
même à l'otan et en plus maxime après il
peut tenter ces petits pièges souvent
comme ça que maxime a battu great food
d'ailleurs tu bluffes marthonie et le
jeu robin truc ça se trouve c'est juste
les meilleurs coups de porter d'autres
parce qu'ils savent possible croit bien
c'est quand même un coût très lourd
après tu le disais il ya le x 6 qui tape
sur la diagonale on met le luron en b1
on s'enlève on s'enlève de ce problème
en plus tu reviens te son compte ou le
rock souvent très content parce que même
si une tour gan c8 t'as pas trop envie
d'un deuxième viseur donc on attend
ouais je vous ai perdu en caméra je vais
nous remettre on a maxime en tout cas là
on grand écran
c'est sûr que great food connaissent et
plus ou moins sûr que maxime connaît
aussi qu'il a déjà vu qu'il a déjà vu
après bah c'est bien de connaître un peu
plus en fait ce que je veux dire c'est
que je pense pas que maxime puisse faire
ce match et ça c'est pas comme vous et
4,2 caruana oui c'est le cas de carole
avons la tête ont su heures tu sais que
tu ne connais tu as perdu là si tu fais
à 5 ou tour c8 ou je sais pas quoi il y
aurait une partie dans tous les cas
n'est pas obligé de jouer le coup machin
donc si tu connais le plan battu quand
même plan il y manque une colonne
hommage non non mais c'est pas pourquoi
je suis aujourd'hui
mais tout est bien
reste qu ce que je vérifier après petit
à petit tout est bon mouais écoute ça
c'est un bon un bon début quand même une
grille ou qui adore la chaise la plus
petite face à la chaise la plus grande
marrant ça c'est qu'il avait déjà fait
ce choix de la chaise la plus pourrie
lorsqu'il avait joué le tournoi en
norvège où tu dois aussi choisir tes
chaise et a pris une toute petite chaise
trappe un peu les choses de manières ce
minuscule il aime bien être sur des
chaises inconfortables c'est bizarre
c'est la fesci autant ces fiches presque
ouais bah ce fischer il voulait pas trop
dans le confort pour garder l'esprit
alerte alerte et de combattants quoi
être là la vue est beaucoup trop belle
dans cette chambre donne moi la vue sur
l'autoroute et les poubelles s'il te
plaît c'est un poète
c'est un poète aux maximes qui commence
à réfléchir sur ce coup on est dans le
lab clairement le fou aussi c'est quand
même partie tempo roi bien et le coup
logique non ils continuent à connaître
1,5 à 5 ans mais on va le voir arriver
sur l'échiquier
j'irai même a thing qu aux fab web est
logique tant qu'infirmier tobon ce que
bon à 4 toit serait mon coup comme ça à
priori que ferait que les blancs un peu
plus loin après le prime pour les blancs
c'est que ça sécurise la casse b4 pour
les noirs bon tu peux te sentir
peut-être moins à l'aise et puis
peut-être qu'à 4 s'est pas encore une
menace parce que tu fais qu'aller prend
bon faire des sacrifices de qualité
maintenant je n'importe lequel premier
qui prend 1,84 ces menaces
donc soit tu fais un coup de dames pour
défendre jardin me trois dames détroit
soit soit tu fais 1,4 alors je suis il
de joie que je suis quand même très
étonnés du choix des rich aucun cette
position maxime i love tellement mieux
que lui c'est évident que maxime est
beaucoup plus fort que great choc dans
ces projets soient pas assez sérieux
pour nous mais enfin le choix est
complètement stupide en réalité ça veut
penser à conjuguer tout le jeu 3 4 oui
mais c'est complètement con mais chez ba
il va au combat
oui mais enfin bon mais ce sens pas
inférieur je savoir il va ajuster nul et
tu comprends pas mais c'est fin c'est
une très bonne nouvelle à on est très
heureux mais je m'appelle il ne peut pas
comprendre et c'est que l'adm a dit
qu'il comprenait pas qu'il était
beaucoup moins fort on peut voir ces
positions l'a d'ailleurs qu'en gris
tchouk avait battu maxime c'est plutôt
dans une grue une file louvoyante nous
voyant tout il avéré vous l'avez réussi
à trouver une
une nouveauté enfin nouveau concept
stratégique même que maxime avait
réutilisé contre ariane paris d'ailleurs
un peu plus d'un an après mais s'est-il
ils avaient plus gagné comme sa grille
tous classés vraiment la position rêvée
pour maxime et après aux douze coups la
fabc ont fait un arrêt sur images on
pouvait pas rêver mieux
soit il va au clash quoi mais wayne
bioshock qui fait son petit bolide dont
c'était une des deux possibilités soit
ça soit allé voir et saine car elle
aurait mieux fait d'aller voir la scène
car c'est dommage pour geek uk non là
j'ai envie de te dire avant la partie on
se demandait maxime nul panula ninna
nanna là aujourd'hui maxime il a
vraiment un
une position en or réellement ça ne peut
pas mieux se passer et gagner c'est
cette partie peut être vraiment la
partie référence du tournoi qui peut qui
peut remettre maxime ont coursé et leurs
maîtres même pas facilement favorise
maxime gagne aujourd'hui maxime est
favori je t'annonce alors j'annonce à
tout le monde en fait donc six à trente
mille spectateurs aujourd'hui maxime
gagnon avec un évident c'est la base
et si maxime gagne maxime re devient co
favori du tournoi avec les peaux et pour
moi la maxime c
là je donne vraiment 40% nul 35% maxime
gagne 25 % great choc
ok je lâche une info j'ai failli dire 40
40 20 cents 0 tu sais non mais si
c'était un mal le maxime qui est de la
forme de 2020 j'aurais donné 40 % nul
45% maxime 15% gris duke c'est juste sa
forme qui fait un peu peur mais en gros
j'attends une victoire rapide du joueur
français
après quatre heures de jeu pour moi
victoire en quatre donc victoire
vraiment l'expédient expéditive en deux
sets gagnants
40 coup 45 coups joués 4 heures fabien
vraiment une victoire très facile et
rapide de
ap ap ouais non mais là je pense à un
truc comme qui avait quatre peut-être
pour les noirs logique un trou qui
rentrent qui rentre là il ya trop de
trous là tu sais tu sais plus où donner
de date à de la tête et grant hill tivat
est dans la tête c'est pas possible
c'est pas possible entre elles à tomber
la veste maxima ratant sa dans la
théorie de ma zone ans et ça c'est plus
calcules tu calcules es-tu l'armée
seyfried sustt et frissonnant c'était
très bien qu'on sait très bien et tu la
rame était très bien on va guetter
longueur mais la veste est ce que ça te
dit un mini tour des stades le temps
qu'ils réfléchissent à son kébé cadres
et raffi kg câbles mais sans lâcher la
cam sans échec à vannes on est calme on
le garde
oui mais gère enfin en bas on les garde
dès que ça jouer alors ça sera fait mais
ça je connais ça dure et pourtant facile
écossaise ouais enfin quatre oui mais
connaissent quand même et qu'est ce que
j'ai dit écossaise à la poubelle
et oui les amis l'écossaise qui tombe au
bc répertoire facile joue sa main avec
les blancs je fais que des nuls très
rapide la balle à sarko tu vois il
voulait faire nul c'était clair
écossaise la plus belle les écossaises
qui tombe mais vous ne joue pas facile
foule écossaise oui
reading 1 ex aequo g5 le spécial spécial
il joue en fait toutes ces parties l'on
donne l'adami ouais ok bon voyage
spécial réponse à partir d'un tas de
petites balles avant de libye non
c'était pas sais pas mais j'ai vu un x 4
intermédiaire mais sinon oui ah oui
c'est le x 4 française issue a expliqué
l'autre jour nous intéresserons sur
maxime tout intéressant serait compliqué
au mans il y aura des deux côtés on peut
attaquer
voilà mais je serais heureux de
l'écossaise donné peau mais c'est très
bien c'est une vente très connus projet
pour faire nul en fait elle est parfaite
salasc en fait les noirs tu peux pas si
tu veux si tu refuses rentrer là dedans
tu es juste moins bien battu souffre et
à pas de chance de gain et viola match
pas si on explique cette position mais
en vrai j'ai pas trop quoi y'a recettes
futures faille juste ci a rien à faire
pour les noirs ils vont regagner le pion
c6 un jour ce sera tout symétrique on
échange tous ont fait nul
moi je fais je faisais un plan marrant
ah oui alors moi j'ai trois un plan
marans et tourbe et un assez mauvais
français ça retourne tour b 4 juste pour
dire fou 4 pas très menacé de me rend
fou mais ça peut faire un nul direct ça
c'est bien mais ça c'est bien tu joues
ça tu fais nul directement ou tu
souffres un peu sauf hernu lien avec
plus ou moins bien c'est bien ben voila
tu fais ça c'est arrivé là tu fais ça
nul non mais tu peux faire plaindre mais
nul n'a peut-être pas besoin d'un rafiot
henri iv tout seul - ouais t'as les
colonnes les colonnes mais ça c'est nul
un droit qui va ça c'est très bien on
vrai ça peut faire feu aux quatre là
c'est très bien mais faut 4 la dame c5
c'est pas nul à nantes
tu bouges l'euro à tour déjà accordé
huit mois je fais un petit plan je fais
tour b 3 ouais tu veux ou alors je fais
d'amin tourbe et un après non mais
attendez ce que je fais pas un peu
différemment maintenant je fais ça j'ai
perdu plein de parties très bon plan
mais ouais je crois que j'ai fait ça
plusieurs fois mais en général quand
j'arrive là je veux juste faire nul en
force à bas mais peut-être tu veux
vraiment faire nul de fait damien dame
français six fours ou quatre dames c'est
50 mb si je sais pas tu es toi c'est
bien ça va être assez bien bien faire
nul à prendre avant du roi tu es bien
des tours ont besoin d'eau de wes assez
là tu fais bien nul comme il faudrait
tours avait huit tours à b1 fou j'ai ici
sien je t'échange temps fou à galati les
fantasmes sont au round 3 du doute un
petit gervais ici ce tour b 1
autour d un bon peu importe cela fait
quatre ans qu'il est en mesure de mener
police
il joue pas ça en disant bon jeu va bien
très chic mais je vais juste pour des en
fait y'a pas d'autres noms pour les
manger sinon tu vas juste être moins
bien en fait si tu la joues tu as juste
fait moins bien qu il a juste fait un
nul n'a aucun intérêt en fait de jouer
avec les blancs mais moi je le joue un
mais c'est c'est vrai ça c'est pas une
ouverture sur boule bien c'est une
ouverture pour faire nul vraiment la fée
foucades direct un donc fait foucades
direct il a dû bien analysé bon tempo
il doit juste savoir en fait tout le
monde s'est tu sais c'est pas et c'est
une position assez connu encore way wii
u départ tient donc il doit il doit
savoir d'accord n'avait rien tenté
battant rennes attentes et surtout
notamment réalité si vous voulez jouer
enfin si vous voulez jouer de manière
plus ambitieuse avec les blancs en fait
c'est ici qu'il faut pas faire cavalier
c3 faut prendre il se rendre 5 comme le
spécial contre ding lors du premier jour
de la reprise sais pas si t'as même pas
fou détroit qui existent ici
non mais si tu veux jouant comme ça tu
peux jouer pour gagner c'est pas
terrible mais je veux dire par là tu vas
avoir une position mais juste d'un
médiateur ne peut rien faire
des quatre prix ce qui allait prendre b4
normale ce qui est fou c'est ça un peu
inférieur au bond du coup ça c'est nul
c'est sûr c'est vraiment 100% guy
reading ça va jouer des matches truqués
en b3 ou qu'il ait fait un petit tour
vers à 5 éventuellement ou faux troqué
ses 5 ou au kerry temps d'un petit truc
hein il joue vite
la ce a réfléchi je sais pas qui ça
arrange s'est tenue l'année pour caruana
s'arrange pour faire baisser sa légende
c'est normal mais mais en fait c'est
normal mais ses fallas aînés pau qui a
séché le jeu direct pour moi les romains
pour moi pour moi n'est peau ne gagnera
pas les candidats avant ça il lui reste
deux noirs mais il veut faire ça tout le
temps fait
personne fera trois sur quatre
puis bon sinon on verra bah je pense
c'est ça son truc j'ai compris mais je
suis d'accord avec toi mais je pense
qu'ils se trompent c'est trop petit slip
nostra planus a toujours dit ces petits
slips ces petits slips mais bon tout cas
il met en place son truc c'est il a d'un
v6 jouer mais il a il avait su avec 5 au
sahara était grotesque de faire ça si tu
fais ça puis après un match aller c'est
grotesque quand même parce que c'est
logique quoi c'est pas c'est spacieux
ses talk icq ne respecte plus jeu
d'échecs lorsque tu fais nul avec les
blancs sans jouer je sais pas qui ça
c'est soit parce qu'ils soient talent
oui mais en fait tu dois pas décorer les
déconnecter le contexte à la partie on
va être en contact c'est qu'ils y bon
sens ça je vais gagner je vais pas
prendre des risques que je jouais un
truc comme on est tous que la quitte à
perdre franchement je suis prêt à
prendre les paris que cette attitude là
c'est une attitude de dauphin c'est
l'autre basse et un dauphin
bungert au bout d'un moment tu veux
gagner les candidats tu veux avoir le
droit d'affronter karl scène
caruana il a pas l'air selon lui dans
les femmes caruana s'il a pas l'air
super en forme dans le milieu de jeu non
je sois tu dois je dois quand même c'est
pas le genre enfin tu vas et tu te
respecte par là ils se respectent pas
les normes c'est cynique mais c'est une
approche car ce n est quand il fait nul
dernière où je viens du monde sans rien
faire contre christine oui mais d'un
gilet noir non ils avaient si elle avait
les droits mais il avait joué un peu il
était à plus ou moins +1 fin tu te dis
[ __ ] il est hyper bien nulle direct
ouais mais ils se respectent pas à
l'époque quand il fait ça ils respectent
pas l'école soviétique des échecs qui se
respecte pas il gagnera pas non mais il
gagnera pas face et ben faut lâcher non
mais je lâche l'info caruana ne gagnera
pas les candidats side pour se calmer
car nous aussi d'ailleurs mais non et
pau ne gagnera pas les candidats les
amis c'est c'est pas une attitude de
champion l'a4 honte de la fin tu as les
blancs contre un adversaire direct qui
fait pas nul comme sa façon il va je te
dire il va suer à grosses gouttes n'est
peau quand maxime va gagner aujourd'hui
ouais
parce que du coup bas maxime il peut
envoyer au lean à la vendée avec les
blancs tu fais quoi tu à refaire une
nulle de pleutres ça est encore pire
bon il verra bien la situation roulant
sera ce moment là mais mais en fait non
je pense qui sait d'ici au 4 5 façons
tout le monde ça il ya un à savoir ça
égalise
pas de quoi que je fasse je peux rien
faire autant que ce soit très clair si
l'autre il veut jouer il va m'en ville
sicilienne il va m'envoyer un truc mon
bal à petit je joue je m'attaque à me
faire une pierre que tu veux quoi je
tombais f4 j'ai envie d'être mais je
suis je suis je suis partagé jeu je sens
que le cip est en train de craquer mais
bon après c'est cadeau
rim s'est fait comme ça ils perdent
quand même la latte et dégoûté un point
moi je te dis que si maxime ou guéries
ou caruana reviennent sur lui il va
complètement implosé mais complètement
tu ne peux pas jouer comme ça aux échecs
c'est pas possible fable c'est pas
possible on verra mais je crois dans les
prédictions de nostradamus qui pour le
moment se vérifie quand même pas mal
excuse moi mais il annonce le tremblant
le petit slip loose cannon le
préparateur ma famille et de tes fort
que dans les ouvertures ça se vérifie et
il annonce tout le spécial qui envoie sa
dame enfin je sais pas abandonné on a
juste parlé à un oracle en réalité avant
le tournoi
le verbal hannover re bon mais que tout
qui séparait nil partie sa bosse que la
maladie la vraie
en suisse pascal sur dame prend des six
savard est rêveur ou la lazio une petite
tournée vite d'avaloirs partir vers a3
couleur pourpre en d1 qui promet quatre
prix oui attentif à bien un atout caché
le beau c'est beau comme c'est une
variante marrante
tiens tu vas te faire mater je suis
athée to be a non mesdames prothésiste
regarde même pas en fait non c'est mal
développé le caillou de jeunes le fouet
fin tu penses à faire j'ai trois vont
certes ont foutu qu'on s'affaire h4 tu
dis j'attaque tu penser à des trucs
comme ça mais tu penses par un autre il
pense même pas ils fument s'appelle
magic qui serait quand même cool que
vous reste plus y rester réaliste n'est
pas de wind avance c'est maxime se suit
constamment au vent on en reparlera
belle maggia on en reparlera dans quatre
jours n'est peau ne gagnera pas les
candidats annoncés ici me battre aussi
si clair c'est face grâce à sa stratégie
début de la ronde a juste à venir et il
veut faire que des nuls et battre avec
thank you who may et s'y tient pour
l'instant mais ça ne suffira pas ça ne
suffira pas il gagnera pas il n'y aura
pas c'est pas grave hein ce sera caruana
sera guéri ou ce sera maxime il a tenté
non mais pour n'est pas le pire scénario
c'est si c'est maxime qui fait trois sur
quatre est pas les autres hypers
vraiment mais dans un autre cas de
figure au pire il va jouer un rapide et
peut-être qui se dit bon bah c'est
caruana peut-être le plus à même de
faire trop sur 4 40 ans rapide je me
sens chaud je m'en fous qu'il fasse ces
trois organes façon je serai là le plus
dangereux pour nepos et maxime ab maxime
c'est juste ils partagent situe comme
tendant et maxime il va gagner
aujourd'hui et va être un demi point ce
soir
après ça peut être changée bon bah tu
veux dire bon bah au pire j'ai blang
maximale à l'avant-dernière bas c'est
elle que je vais jouer je veux dire à ça
ça peut être une strate alors ah oui
alors là oui alors là oui mais il faut
va pas falloir être petit slip jusqu'au
bout oui tu pars en mode petit slip à
dire ça peut suffire pas ce que ça peu
puis tu vois le classement comment ils
évoluent cissé carnac et revient dessus
tu peux dire oui bon c'est pas grave ça
selon lui je l'attends de pied ferme
c'est guy ritchie rioux pas moins fort
qui rit non plus rapide c'est maxime tu
sais pas si t'as pas le choix on fait
donc tata parties à jouer
sera-t-il en condition mentale pour la
jouer c'est une autre question
ah non mais après ben c'est parce que tu
joues tu gagnes en plus il peut se dire
que maxime est aussi amène de craquer du
coup ce sera cracotte vs cracotte et les
crains que ça peut ça peut se passer
quoi bonjour ça on ne va pas chez
bascule dans la tête mais il a quand
même de quoi de quoi adapter ce qui se
passe déjà demain talent et noir
mondiaux de gagner peut-être un
subterfuge et cinq policiers la dame
il peut tout faire on verra enfin ça me
ma confiance en maxime tu en es 20% de
chance à maxime de gagner les candidats
là je suis passé à 25,30 même 30% la
main avec ce début de partie
ça monte ça monte maintenant là ça monte
entre le début de paragraphe contre la
nul 2 2 n'est peau qui me rassure qui
est le meilleur résultat et gris chucky
fait une tête d'enterrement parce que
ils se rappellent plus de dame b 6
franchement le mix des deux me fait
plaisir
yakhi à caruana qui marche derrière qui
est en train de dubitatif demander
qu'est-ce que je fais là
maxime l'aller la côte de maxime remonte
en flèche
franchement c'est première demi-heure
rêvée pour le moment il ya des partis
pour une demi-heure de minimum de
réflexion mais je pense que j'ai
peut-être même une heure là ça peut
durer vraiment a great ou kaki qui sont
dans une telle réflexion
regarde regarde sa tête est-ce qu'ils
aient la tête de quelqu'un qui va gagner
cette partie non à un moment donné est
ce qu'on sait pour que je la fais un
famille fabien ben ouais c'est bon
tiffany qui passe tu regardes trop
distrait il est distrait alors ça le
soul regarde ça le soul et l'a1 pense
madame au repos ça soit il sait que
maxime est plus fort que lui dans ses
positions c'est ça aussi la qui vient
complète c'est que maintenant il le sait
je le rappelle il s'en est pas mal à
voir la partie se rappelle maintenant il
et j'ai toujours su 1 mais il a espéré
que maxime ne connaissent pas son petit
cavalier e 2c dit je vais être très
malin maxime connaît tous il ya tout
envoyer tempo par le tempo il s'est
remémoré mais il a envoyé les coups
quand même assez rapidement et là il
sait mais fable langage corporel est
tellement en faveur de maxime regardent
ils bouffent son pansement c'est un
genre de rn je ne peux pas me
transformer le poste morin cas issue ne
peut pas se mordre
bestiale regard son équipement quoi
c'est très ingénieux émaille son petit
coussin vert assorti la non mais là la
petite le petit fauteuil ministériel il
est bien la veste est posé il a fait
l'achat ce matin dans l'ascenseur il est
au top et fabiano issue soit issue ez
wheel maxime est mieux qu est ce que je
vais faire ce que je peux gagner ça non
et oui j'avais tout calculer et miser
sur un nul contre l'épaule je peux le
rattraper les maximes qui gagne c'est
vraiment un gros problème pour moi il
fait le tour eiffel à paris dont il sait
plus où il en est et gris tout pareille
issue voilà tatoué qu'un terrain bourque
issue 1 c'est un tremblement de terre un
voile alors il ya même les arbitres
sinotte et notent les coûts de maxime
tient bien sûr à 12 dames b6 très bons
coups mais pour l'extermination et le
choc est issu il regarde la barre
chocolatée de maxime il veut lui voler
et regarder la barre et ouais ça mais je
crois qu'ils auront parti pour nous
faire c'est une demi heure ah bah oui il
est au fond là ma barbe n'a pas assez
poussé tombe de rythme je passe qui
regardent peut-être lagarde maxime en
train de ce match et quel beau gosse ce
mac séries tu vois non c'est guéri
regardez je suis bleui à eloïse c'est le
s mais il est
bien grisha non mais regardez vraiment
pas bien tu me fais griller choc qu'est
ce qui me fait mon sacha de l'écran on
va pas la cam matin il ya un écran qui
diffuse chaque parti voit les regarde
ces bouteilles d'eau rend très heureux
car de la 2d c'est des petites flèches
dans sa tête
alors après van aertryck marans et qui
peut savoir le coup il affirmé je veux
améliorer quand je me rappelle de ce
qu'il faut faire mais je vais attendre
une bonne heure avant de le jouer je
suis bien sûr que c'est g3 pour
développer le fou j'ai regardé la ligne
juste avant la partie et ils pensent
tous que je perds une heure à réfléchir
mais je sais que c'est le coup je suis
bien au courant il ne s'en doute
vraiment pas vraiment pas tus et fabien
juste 30 ans que je fais ça mais
toujours pas compris je suis beaucoup
plus dangereux avec trois minutes avec
1h20 mais ils ne le savent pas je crois
qu'il veut je vais peut-être way dans la
tête de quelqu'un qui va jouer à la main
qui dirigera le plonger ou acheter un
truc je crois vraiment qu'ils se
rappellent honnêtement il a plus la tête
de quelqu'un qui se remémore affiché
plus éloignés de fichiers de vlad non
mais
s'il aimait bien réfléchir même quand
ils connaissent appui des fois il
changea je vais pas le coup qui connaît
ça parce que bruit en fait chier au vous
pourquoi pas s'en faire très fort il est
là il passe ça arrive ça souvent une
mauvaise idée mais lui-même bien parce
que bon il ne faisait pas des prêts pad
non tu peux tu peux le faire entre
guillemets hicham était très fort mais
jusqu'à un certain niveau là où ils
peuvent plus le faire en fait je pense
qu'en jusqu à 2729 tu peux faire mais je
pense qu'ils peuvent vraiment pas le
faire on dit que l'ordi pour conseille
plutôt h4 on va avoir un il va il va par
la voix des sages et roanne 4 c'est un
des deux coups je sais pas lequel il va
faire mais ça peut pas être autre chose
je pense
il est ici to you is et intéresse
comme moment quand même un fab me maxime
qui conduit la politique de la chaise
vide entre les coins mais il fait son
concours de marche ouais c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui n'est pas à prendre du
retard sur le concours de marche
ingénieux rallye défini beaucoup trop
vite peut-être qu'il va les marchés de
son côté beauté est-ce que ça compte
non je crois pas que soient comptables
cnc doit vraiment être pendant ta partie
quoi c'est une obligation réglementaire
ça pour le concours de marche passion ça
laisserait trop de gens y participer je
remets maso mais là ce sera très bien
ouais super condition tu fais la chaise
il rayonne
ils allaient jouer mais non je préfère
prendre trois quarts d'heure de plus je
sais pertinement comme dans les mangas
quand il anime et olive et tom je sais
pertinemment que je jouerai le kw/h 4
mais je vais attendre pour bien me
rappeler de mes entraîneurs quand
j'avais 9 ans je que devient ben baker
ça tu séchage a poussé le pion h
lorsqu'il y a un enfant qui tousse est
vraiment très fort pour attaquer le roi
il m'avait montré cette partie de bobby
fischer contre marseille oui avec le fou
en b3 mais ici j'ai un four b2 mais ce
n'est pas grave grâce à la force de
l'amitié
le four b2 tapera dans la diagonale je
m'attends à tout un art comme ça il
finit par jouer son courroux docteur oui
oui oui et le couillard jonah hill bouge
le piot et ça a duré 30 secondes
roberto et bien lorsque j'avais 14 ans
j'ai quitté le japon pour aller jouer
une saison en russie
donc à quoi s'attendre en d6 bon on a
déjà montré c'est juste moi y'a tour des
vite la dame se retrouve très mal placé
1 à 3 puis les blancs sont défoncés
remontera pas évident à 20,3 on prend la
tour en d1 on fait ce qu'il faut et puis
tu vas t'en avec ta dam pour te prends
le 4k et des 2 arrive qu'ils aient b46
catastrophique un raid et l'harmonie des
pièces blanches dont adam prend des six
non ça ne ce possible soit g3 pour
défendre et prépare peut-être faire fou
j'ai deux rames et la tourache en jeu en
vaut soit bon je te fais h 4 h 5
en avant guingamp quoi je serais plus un
membre du team usa 3g un calcul et et
des cinq noms gérer non oui ça c'est sûr
et puis bon pronostiqueur les cinq est
attaqué on a pas qui c'est 3 pour
défendre parce qu'il y avait fui après
évidemment la tour c 8 mai qui à dessein
que c'est une bonne idée un jour
peut-être
c'est clair que c'est une belle occase
cependant ces structures c'est bien de
l'occuper ça peut être bien même les
changes puis on prend pour enlever le
cavalier fragiliser le 5 mai et encaisse
clouage du flashy sur la dame des deux
je sais pas je trouve pas d'organisation
tu as une deux trois quatre cinq pièces
parfaitement développée pour les noirs
tu en as pour les blancs une deux trois
voilà tour du 4 mai et est à deux coups
de sortir la cinquième tu as un vrai
retard de développement et a quand même
une pression f4 donc le coup j'ai 3 sur
5 je me levais 3 mais après c'est
possible que l'analyse bâche 4 soit
juste plus facile vainqueur fin ce qui
m'inquiète c'est ce qui m'inquiète pour
green shoots ses cahiers g4 parce que tu
me l'as déjà de rentrer en f2 c'est
peut-être pas grave je sais pas raison
pression que les noirs ont déjà plus
qu'à égaliser mais bon allez on va
prendre le coût de leur dit qu on tour
c'est un donc je vois pas vraiment mieux
skf de c'est pas très grave et puis 2 en
3 h trois cavalières 3 bon allez on y va
hk trou qui s'est alors dit change
d'avis hommage catherine vautrin accords
de branche 4 1 en fait ces robustes
l'europe des blancs je veux dire c'est
ça le problème parce que j'ai joué assez
souvent ce truc
mais bon plus ambitieux j'ai fait qu'une
partie lente ou de dessus on m'a jamais
joué 6 x 6 3 qui va bien quoi mais on
arrive pas à planter des cayes ces
quatre joueurs de queen marche pas alors
ça peut marcher
non mais un sous la mairie spa qui est
peut-être des fous ces quatre ambulants
mais c'est un peu lent ça me passe rien
en vrai dommage c'était joli guide et
d'emploi tu as perdu
mais ouais faut des cas tu le laisses
bien ses cartes puis tu fais h 5 mai
mais je sais pas enfin au nom mais kg
4,7 peut être un souci tout à fait wesh
pas je ferais g3 comme ça mais mais bon
peut-être que ce soit aussi joué pour
tour des huit des 5,1 peut-être bas ça
serait typique davantage de l'autre mon
tour oui mais ça faut vraiment calculé
objets 2 c'est peut-être maintenant kg 4
pour que gueye 3 arrive sur tempo
à j-4 relief 2 h 5 e enfants 5
mais c'est sur un truc comme ça ne fait
pas que défendre avec les vrais reprend
f2f deux coussins pas ouais mais c'est
tellement dans le style de maxime ses
positions normalement il joue très très
bien note notre max très tactique très
bon du tout je sais pas pourquoi pas
jouer plus tard il avait la main qui
partait puis là il fait la sieste
écoute c'est le début de partie vraiment
rêver hein c'est j'ai envie de te dire
chaque minute qui passe en plus me
rassure puisque cette note
bah oui là on tombe vraiment dans le cas
de figure où great chioukh s'endort il
ya trop de possibilités on tombe
exactement dans ce qu'on voulait c'est
le scénario de rêve
c'est vraiment le scénario de rêve face
à gries tchouk surtout tu vois la même
position contre eux n'est pas je serai
beaucoup moins confiant qu'on ne fait
habiller ou ça calcule bien quand même
ouais mais la grille tout qui peut
vraiment passé une heure à 0,8 g 3 kg et
qu'à tout calculé jusqu'au bout suis
fait tout rêve des 8es pas tour débute à
moi j'avais pas regardé je recommence
mais tu sais qu il le fait souvent ça et
là encore fait contre eux ou en garde
s'il a réfléchi 1h12 et il avait regardé
5 possibilités pour gao est la seule qui
n'a pas regardé c'est le coup de vent
que wang hao lui a joué ça lui arrive
assez souvent de fer s'annonce surtout
dans ce genre de position il ya un grand
éventail de coups pour la tgca szczesny
des tours des vitrines et des tours sont
utilisés et b4 aussi est allé deux cas
les deux tours en plus ne peuvent y
aller pour celui dont on s'est plutôt
l'accord qui est g4 tu peux avoir des
trucs à éduquer et d4 un jour du cac et
b4
j'ai juste un oeil pour voir si c'est
déjà nu le côté ça va l'être rapidement
oui tout va être liquidée on va pas
perdre de temps dessus et j'ai juste dit
à reading et leeds à 1,5 et baning qui
ronge une partie compliquée ça va être
loin mais
bompard va pas ce que dira composé de
faire du hcc 5 le tout poussé aussi on
aura le temps de revenir dessus
juste avant de voir les pendules en
faire une ligne à y rester une heure
vingt ce qu'on peut étayer les idées sur
l'ouverture dont on a déjà parlé un
matou cas tu as et les blancs c'est
pousser à l'endroit est attaqué le roi
noire les noirs ces attaques et le roi
blanc face et ouais mais ç'a été cinq
peut-être pour les noirs en fait je veux
dire si c'est que attaques contre
attaque dans les blancs plus facile h 4
h 5 va partir alors que les noirs ont eu
le même plan bloqués et b5 tu feras pas
par contre le truc c'est que dans un jeu
de pièces plus actifs ils sont mieux
développer donc il ya des cayes g4 qui
peuvent jaillir des tours c'est lui qui
avait quatre des poussées tour des huit
pour percer au centre donc c'est plus
dangereux là que les noirs vont faire
des choses mais si les blancs arias
finale développement sans encombre ça
peut être dangereux en vrai c'est même
pas il ya même pas vraiment de plan
c'est vraiment concret fable gérer la
serrant les positions ou c'est qu'on
apprend maxime très concret en faites
pas ce que je dois faire si ça les
blancs en fait je peux dire assez facile
il me le faire j'ai trois fous j'ai 2 h
4 h 5 non mais on peut s'en passer
mais après le truc c'est que ça c'est un
peu du coup par coup
c'est à pas il n'y a pas un plan précis
s'il faut calculer faut voir ça marche
ou ça marche pas en vrai c'est un peu du
fin c'est pas du coup par coup mais
c'est du mna petites menaces défense
est-ce que tu as le temps de le faire
vous tapez pas le temps de le faire et
c'est que du concret là y'a pas
il ya pas vraiment de plan ben y'a pas
un plan soit ainsi des fois on peut dire
oui vivre moi de la pièce ici tout s'est
parfaitement bien pions faibles ondées 6
on pourrait paraître ça comme problème
stratégique est en fait blanc tous ces
structures c'est le cas mais dès qu'ils
allaient rock opposé en fait c'est la
sécurité des rois qui passe en premier
plan et la tactique et tout ça donc ça
empêche pas que peut-être sur un échange
de dames et c'était avec ce qu on
reviendra faible un jour sa mère
l'actuel c'est juste pas un facteur
c'est ça c'est c'est le problème
donc c'est très concret comme jeu là
c'est vraiment très concret ouais là on
est vraiment dans le dans le type de
position ou la mise à part dire c'est
concret que dans d'autres et ça dépend
de chacun d'écouter deux joueurs peuvent
changer les enjeux de la position dans
votre budget vous que je côtoie pas moi
je ferais pas pour valser une fois
compatible pour ce soir mais qui
réfléchiront tu vois qu'on est bon ben
voilà il a joué jusqu'à trouver la fédé
3 rennes pendant une heure et demie
ouais mais monde pourquoi les joueurs
marchent pas pour le concours en fait le
grand concours un concours très serré
entre guy m
ouais c'est vraiment les deux grands
favoris à toutes les compétitions ils
l'emportent série marche bien ils sont
fous on s'est toujours dit qu toujours
l'un des deux hommes qui a réussi à
remporter ce trophée du marcheur ils
n'ont pas été chalenge et depuis depuis
maintenant presque une demi douzaine
d'années sont vraiment bien bien bien au
dessus du lot avec guy quand même
légèrement favori un très long j'ai dit
l on tienne longue regardez la belle
foulée un ouais elle foulait je me suis
adapté très souple il faut être il a
aussi une très belle préparation
théorique un fab leur éviter partir web
est un portrait que fait un énorme
travail là dessus pour arriver vraiment
dans les conditions optimales pour pour
ces compétitions il a il a un régime
alimentaire vraiment calibrer au gramme
près maxime plus un joueur en force rien
cours de marche s'il avait remporté il
est enchaîné
non non c'est plus plus plus en force
mais c'est aussi un bon marcheur alors
on va guérir inquiète repasser devant la
cam
par contre il repassera par la great flu
par contre le coût cours de marche
non non il sait pas du tout motivé
d'harry s'est même blessé à la main lors
de ses entraînements il a raté son la
seule ouais il a il a trébuché sur sur
l'eau de la main et il s'est fait une
petite entorse au poignet voilà sa façon
c'est trop bête mais il faisait pas
partie des favoris de notre façon
d'ailleurs on voit y réfléchit bien trop
pour le concours de marche c'est
vraiment un défaut maxime qui même s'il
ne connaissait pas la préparation de son
adversaire a quand même tenu le rythme
ternaire qu'un petit set
suit un qui suit qui suis guéri regard
non il le suivait de base ont été
largués ouais bah oui on voit trop trop
appuyé du néerlandais le rythme du
néerlandais qui qu'il acheta une
nouvelle fois fabiano il a déjà quelques
tours d'avancé guéri ou la brique est
sorti du peloton
car on ne peut pas suivre là où il veut
en venir je préfère pour tout retard
quoi faire attention quand même un des
six sprints comme ça ça peut coûter en
fin de journée un bain après trois
quarts des acquis qui montrent une
époque a fait une belle performance
contre alex enhco d'ailleurs avant-hier
marché pendant une heure et demie
c'était impressionnant
c'était un sprint en quasiment très bien
que j'aie des vélos d'appartement
c'est quand même tu as déjà vu ce jeu
c'est un maxime qui décide de se
rasseoir il commence un petit peu un
coin c'est un gars non non tu sais tu as
ta des vélos d'entraînement à la maison
qui se connecte à un genre de jeu vidéo
arrive je connais tu roules seraient
énormes qu'ils aient des vélos comme ça
roule à fond ils ont la course entre eux
et tu retransmet les deux compétitions
en même temps car il doit aller très
vite jouée pour revenir il est lâché il
serait dans la roue ce qui est
extraordinaire
1 s'appelle swift way est l'hôte
vallotton de points oui bien sûr ou
alors des tapis de marche où tu marches
pareil tu les vois et ça alors de
marathon serait magnifique sérieuse whif
tu pourras les candidats serait
magnifique extraordinaire ça serait beau
ce serait extraordinaire
je pense que j'y serai
favori en plus il est longiligne et je
pense qu'il est assez léger il a un
physique de cyclistes ouais mais parce
qu'il a des muscles qui vont avec mais
jarcy s'entraîne il peut être très bon
parce que dans l'est dans l'école s'est
battue sans la pente et tout est une
acquisition qui vient sur wii je pense
bien sûr d'appui sur les plaideurs et
bien sûr c'est vraiment une ré
simulation je pense guy pour être
vraiment très fort
il ya vraiment un sport physique de
cyclistes aux attentes je suis pas athée
sûr que sur le jeu vidéo ça va jouer son
va être en vraie vie mais c'est sûr tu
traînes ton poids oui mais là aussi
c'est avec le calcul sa mêlée ça dure
cité [ __ ] au fond de ton pote ben oui
bien sûr enfin le gros régime avant le
tournoi et je mange bien des bons big
mac mais c'est combien de guiry pour
dépasser contador je pense que guy est
beaucoup plus tour de france que rugby
oui probablement chance avec un peu
d'entraînement il faut faire très très
mal à jonah lomu aux vélos vélos rugby
un peu moins jeu
1h 13 donc ça fait quoi c'est une bonne
vingtaine de minutes là qui est sur la
position
je suis assez contente ce qui regarde
vers les dames c'est peut-être le cas
llambi 5 tu sais ce qui est des cinq sa
perte terrible week et prend un cadre m
alors si l'on soit bon mais là non
équilibré 4 ça met fin au débat avec la
dame fort chatons suite l'arrivage voilà
h4 c'est du coup qu'il avait envie de
jouer yahia mais il mettait sa main par
là bas je suis sûr qu'il connaît veut
nous faire quelques pas quand même le
truc c'est que suis sûr qu'il se
rappelle sa mi-temps sera plantes c'est
possible je savais qu'il faille échoué à
quatre et je le fais comme prévu j'étais
déçu il ya déjà quinze minutes que
j'avais joué ce coup d'ailleurs y'a plus
personne à la table de maxime va arriver
assez vite après tout ça jusqu'à 3 et
qui était le coup de plus logique
je suis quasiment sûr que c'est le
cookie dont son fichier maxime qui a
rien pas plus impressionné que ça mais
bon il n'a pas mis la veste pour autant
est-ce que ça peut être intéressant
c'est parti au lieu de se lever
justement de rester concentré de 10
rascal c'est le coup logique de bien
et le joug du raja et le jouet du tempo
mais on peut marcher et netbooks qui
regardent même message à me sens qu'il
ya personne qui le fait quasiment à haut
niveau
j'en ressens qu'il réfléchisse quasiment
jamais sur le dotant de l'adversaire
avec quand il marche et réfléchissent en
fait mais tu réfléchis pas moins bien
quand tu marches le quand tu es assis
non parce que j'ai l'impression que les
joueurs soviétique à l'époque genre
c'était interdit de se lever autant ils
étaient très concentrés sur leur chaise
il restait il se met drame est un jeu
pour sa part dit est trop longue pour
être à fond à 100% tout le temps tu veux
pas en fait faut que tu aies des moins
de souffle et en fait donc rebond leur
marche elle sert aussi à un peu détendre
mais tu restes focus sur ta partis en
train à moi quand je jouerai pour moi je
suis pas dans la tête des autres mais je
peux aller me dire qu'est ce que je vais
manger ce soir ou que je lui dire où je
pense je pense à la partie quoi donc en
fait comme on peut très bien facilement
jouer l aveugle
tu sais très bien ce sont les pièces du
calcul ça va et des fois tu avais des
idées comme ça que tu vois pas vraiment
de rôle un chèque voilà auprès des fois
mais surtout tu prends le ca vous qui
divaguent qui pensent à autre chose mais
c'est plutôt pas très bon signe
après le procès comme j'allais les gens
qui vont maintenant le chat je pose la
question mercredi dame ce que moi je me
levais tout le temps pour réfléchir us
et pour faire une passe à fab
merci non mais après tu as des joueurs
qui aiment plus balader et d'autres
astuces à six mois je pense je suis plus
en fait pas ça dépend en fait mais en
plus ça tu évacue le stress quand je
faisais partie très important je marche
beaucoup et assez vite d'air je serai
très dangereux pour le concours je parle
à personne je m'en fous je regarde rien
je suis là mais si l'on s'attend à
lambda et que je fais là pareil qu'au
mexique à part en mode sieste maxime a
tellement un style différent dans le
langage corporel par rapport à great
thou great succès la petite chaise
concentration
maxime c'est très tranquille c'est
fantastique
oui je baille je regrette les yeux je
sois tranquille et tout d'un coup dès
qu'il va y avoir une faute de grichting
le reste des blues
tiens tiens de faire une erreur là
maintenant je ne m' avachi plus du tout
je vais te défoncer c'est marrant maxime
c'est vrai que tu vas tu sens et petite
position j'ai plusieurs options peut
faire kg 4 je peux jouer tour des tu
fais ton rêve des huîtres tranquille tu
sens très tranquille et d'un coup à
tient ce coup n'appartient pas la
position maintenant famille de douze
coups vous forcer un psy pourquoi des
six n'est pas prêt vous remettra un
réponse du bot des six très mauvais ce
qui est hors des huit fait je pense
jamais un tour des huit j'ai passé là
aussi c'est la ft un côté l'aef c'est
plus logique d'un autre côté tu
t'éloignes un peu de ton roi jeu très
bref mais bon peut-être juste pour parce
que c'est kitsch ou que tu fous truc pas
logique t'as pas regarder ça mais tu
peux dire que tu vas faire tour à tour
est fille s'y attaquer ou quatre plus
tard alors qu'est des quatre pages c'est
pas juste comprendre tu fais refrain f 4
mai 2002 et le fou rire puis bon bah du
coup l'autre cases noires faire mal
selon la grande diagonale
ça marche pas du tout non mais en fait
le but là c'est pas de gagner des pions
jamais d'un et qui traîne et que c'est
gratuit on va quand même le bouffer mais
[Musique]
c'est qu'un des potions recomposée tout
ça et donc les pièces ils peuvent
attaquer et
c'est important les noirs c'est
hyperbare dans gears bien sûr et sain
que je pense le plus longtemps possible
pour museler le four b2 parce que sinon
évidemment très dangereux parce qu'il
est trop partout l'avantagé c'est qu'il
est bien muselé puisque le pion f4 qui
m'aiment et cloud et met donc on est
loin de le perdre
peut-être un jour adam bougera discorde
y propose québec a tracé un coup que je
peux comprendre que ça renforce la casse
des cinq ans peuvent être des problèmes
en les blancs doivent faire du h 5 ou 6
e dan prendrait six menaces en l'air
c'est moins grave que de thaler c'est
plus de tour des huit tout de suite vu
que c'est perdre à la dame mais as-tu
fait ça je pensais peut-être à juste
échangé autour des mythes mais peut-être
f
et tu t'en vas tu reviennes ok mais ça
c'est très dur à faire interdire c'est
assez brillant mais jura provence
affaire qui est délicate voir beauf et
depuis on dira tiens enfin je reviens je
te marche je suis fait dam des trois
tours machin on s'en va vous en f3 ou
ouais ça serait logique vers les cieux
du couvent les 500 moins roulé dessus
comme ça expliquait dans l'air ouais mon
tour de me b 5
ouais non mais c'est marrant québec
admet alain franchement si fait après
moi j'ai rien alors dis parce que je
suis parti du principe qu'ils étaient
encore dans leur prépa et donc du coup
ils ont pu voir à l'idée on a senti la
fringale du joueur français qui se
nourrit ils étaient ravitaillés par son
équipier descendu à l'arrière du peloton
et qui remonte sa je suis dit là les
retours du cavalier du raterait les
bains dacor ac quasiment introuvable
mais le truc c'est que s'ils sont
préparés que c'était quelque part dans
ton fichier tu l'as déjà vu tu sais que
c'est une manne qui peut exister que ça
peut exister donc ça vient trouvable
c'est toujours pareil mais j'y crois pas
trop mais on vient ça dépend si tu l'as
vu aussi l'a pas vu vraiment si tu l'a
jamais vu c'est introuvable si tu as
déjà vu mais si tu a révisé le matin
c'est bon ça souvent on vous dit que la
nage d'orves de maxime c'est c'est un
peu compliqué pour lui que ses
adversaires ont des bonnes prépa dans le
sens où ils ont révisé les fichiers le
matin et c'est justement pour ce genre
de manoeuvre que c'est important d'avoir
révisé le matin parce que si tu sais
pertinemment que tu auras une position
va dire celle là tu sais que tu voir
cette position-là enfin qu'elle peut
avoir lieu et que tu as regardé un peu
d'âme b6 h4 et que tu as vu les des
plombs à base de québec 4 à tien je peux
donner le plus à revenir en c6 cela lui
serve le matin bas d'après tu regardes
tu dis ah tiens mais ici est ce que ça
marche et puis tu regardes un point des
six qui a essayé six ans tu sais plus
cesser si tu ne sais plus si c'est ici
précisément mais bon tu commences à
regarder puisse te rends compte oui bon
bah si fait dam des deux je sais pas je
vais commencer à mettre une tour en des
huit charges et un change s'éprend du
cai je reprends le quartier reprendre la
dame
vercol une tour en des 8 puis ça a l'air
intéressante à une deux trois quatre
cinq six pièces développées contre trois
ouvriers qui sont bizarrement placée en
dames c1 dames f2 fattu voilà que tu es
complètement gagnant du coup si si tu as
vu ça il ya un mois tu vas pas te
rappeler tu peux enfin la direction de
pétrole et ce match peut mais mais bon
ça peut être un peu faim voilà c'est
vraiment un peu de réussite entre
guillemets mais si tu as pu voir le
fichier le matin que je savais qu'ils
allaient jouer ça vraiment le cavalier
bekkat il est largement dans ses cordes
on met un truc choquant que vous à tous
le souvenir quant aux femmes cette
marque mais c'est choquant en fait ça
paraît vraiment supra bizarre après je
sais pas quel point c'est si fort dame
prend des six qui sait si ce d'amener
300 kw à tour des dames b5 du coup vont
essayer changé d'avis parce qu'on peut
mais ouais tu te sent un peu à l'étroit
avec les blancs quand tu as vraiment en
retard de développement
bon ça reste chaud h5 c'est chaud ouais
je prendrai les noms et ça même si c'est
assez bizarre de ces pièces qui bouge
pas mais ça que ça peut aller vite
finalement mais oui bon kg 4 ça me
semble plus logique a priori autour des
8 bien sûr bien sûr c'est des coups que
autour des 8 ses rangs le coup franc
vite joué très long quand même tu
défends ton sur les normands et le tour
5 pouces et sur air france aura des
princes mais ça fera des parents est
toujours à quoi l'on était bien placé
sur sa colonne et ça va donc une bonne
idée et par sucre et ça provoque un pic
d'insuline bon c'est parce que c'est un
comme bach précisément par sucre et la
ratatouille anbar peut-être une paire de
gants bon à voir en tout cas position
compliquée ils sont très vite dans le
vif du sujet on va voir la comax réagit
à tout ça mais ouais donc comme on vous
dit un tour des huit l'une ou l'autre
pour ces huit bien sûr jouable kg 4 et
la solution de leurs 10 km et 4 me
semble injouable
si la pav eu l'idée avant sur l'ordi ou
dans ses fichiers à fronsac des feuilles
de partis attention mais bien le i sur
le point sur le i de grid choses et le
fait quand même moins que le jeu sort un
jeu d'aaron ses divisions de l'iri et
des mêlées on est le gros plan
d'ailleurs la preuve
archi qui a frappé quoi les gens voient
une première puis une heure après une
heure de jeu la femme je viens de voir
est 14h02 c'est l'heure de mettre la
première pub on va la mettre à une belle
une belle pub mon fab a une belle pub
comme on les nomme way fait plaisir
cette pub petite pub de trois minutes
ça fait du bien à tout le monde fab
basque un meilleur monde u stream ça
permet d'un petit peu d'un petit peu
réfléchir pour tout le monde de
reprendre sa respiration au maximum
on a des gens qui sont contents parce
qu'ils n'ont pas eu non pas la pub mais
moi je serais très déçu de ne pas avoir
la pub puis c'est fabien très bien c'est
vraiment très décevant qu'elles soient
pas ouvertes avait plus d'or à défaut il
y en a qui sont arrivés à retardement
des filles qui n'avaient pu voir que tu
es bon maxime en réflexion alors le
danger un pour maxime on en a peu parlé
puisqu'on était sur ce plan de cavale et
b4 mais c'est simplement h5 d'ouvrir la
colonne âge sur ce x justice qui est
assez mal placé
et de souligner que will temps fou et
très bien placé parce que tu me cloue le
pion f4 et et j'ai la dame en d2 mais je
vais juste le chasser via h5 et tu vas
devoir perdre un temps avec vous j'ai 7
et je vais venir m'incruster colonna jeu
voire même prendre le 5 et 6 le faux
obligé de repartir en g7 ce sera une une
énorme concession pour les noirs bon des
fois tu oublies de voir partir ce que tu
as quand même fait mettre les blancs de
manière bizarre mais c'est un temps de
perdu quelque part m et si tu fais bien
de souligner ce soit qui s'il est bien
pour lui cette diagonale mais c'est une
pièce pas protégé donc s'il est blanc
arrive à taper dessus et cash 5 h congé
si ces problématiques
surtout que h5 c'est le cocktail rizhao
staff et h quatre en tout cas mais je
dirais même contre cette structure deux
options globalement contraint fiant
kétou h45 c'est tellement thématique la
masterclass de fab
ouais chk tâches informatiques et
surtout démontrer la gca pacha parties
karpov korcz mail et tout ça est ce
qu'une cave alliage 5 et une option ici
s'est adjugé 3 bondi dans cette éloigne
pas pu la pousser des 5
ça donne du temps aux blancs c'est ce
qu'ils voulaient je peux aussi grave
j'aime pas 3.45 contresens as un peu à
contre sens tu te retrouves avec eux
c'est ce cavalier se fout qu'ils tapent
sur f4 mais qui est blindé était super
vraiment le contrôle du centre mais d'un
autre côté tu peux te dire que le kava
lieu de est un peu bloquée il faudra
voir des fois h 3o ci après
mais juste une question rassemble deux
stars doj qui demandait si on se prend à
11,5 avec les noirs et puis qu'on
réagisse parce que j'ai cette histoire
que ça pue reprise prise est ce qu'il
vaut mieux bloquer par h6 ou reprendre
bas c'est quand même mieux de reprendre
la recontre voilà par contre pas de h
parce qu'en fait 2h si les blancs amène
la dame par mme dam des trois dames j'ai
trois dames h 40 jeu c'est pas un truc
comme ça c'est vraiment rouvert en
prenant de f
bon tu as toujours ton clan h7 talent et
tours qui monte sur la septième rangée
un petit tour f7 qui défend raison
tellement un moment donc normalement
c'est plus solide même s'il a bon si on
avait cette position là précisément ça
pourrait craindre pour les noirs un peu
parce que ça qu'on s'a ouvrir mais c'est
une bonne idée en fait de se laisser
bouffer pour fermer quand le pion peut
pas continuer sa course
la rangée cissé pourrait continuer de
pousser d'autres pions en fait on
fermerait pas grand chose finalement les
colonnes sont calmes ouvertes et les
pions fait un avalanche
je crois qu'on sait plus quand il ya un
flux enquêteurs très peu de 4 pas le
seul car en fait si le puits est en âge
c'est très gentil pour un set fut roi
suite oui hélas l'arrière tu pourrais te
dira tiens ce jeu fait un bouclier quoi
mais bon c'est quand même c'est bayonne
qui est hausse est pas fréquent et 1 cas
sur marrant mais je sais pas du tout
comment le maître c'est qu'on ya g4 g5
ya plus pions h fête à mach 2 h 5 si on
prend un virage 7
je veux parler mais là je sais pas du
tout comment je peux le montrer ouais
c'est au match
position à 0 non mais je peux faire ça
je peux expliquer quoi j'échange les
fous aussi dans le sens d'un petit
barrage trois fois fou prend dames on
dit il faut prendre avec existe pas on
va dire qu'il rangeait 8
voilà qu'on était un jour qu'on va faire
on va faire ce genre de cas de fuite
deux cas de figure où on a l'impression
qu'ils adam prend 1,7 matt imparable sur
alicia dame problème si c'est d'un match
mais en réalité on peut faire h5 on
force a pris en passant en force
d'ailleurs avec les hauts revenus
pourraient mieux c'est ici de ramener
une pièce pour sacrifier genre cavaliers
ou de fous par jets de f3 et pour tout
péter dira tiens je vais quand même
rentrer mais bon admettons qu'on prenne
les trois sets et la voilà on a le cas
de figure où on se sert du but adverse
comme bouclier c'est un truc qui peut
s'oublier ça quand tu calcules moi ça
m'est arrivé d'oublier ce truc là lors
d'une vente un peu lointaine studio
galande colonna je vais mater et où
vicky h5 prise en passant rage cet homme
c'est typique des beaux mâles de 6 m de
chez belin guy blanchette fonds g4 g5
tour f 3 tours h3n2 la dame
ben merde h56 défendre un coup en fait
c'était ribéry s'est dit quoi préparer
voilà peut-être dû mettre l'échiquier en
grand il faut la refaire mais alors
maxime fages voilà maxime va jouer c'est
sûr alors c'est un coup à l'aide d'un
tournoi des huit tours à ses huit bons
les deux sont autorisés à les enlever
ok des huit en faire des saints qu'on
aime bien après tour s'est vite une
torsion des colonies woerth écoutez
c'est pas du tout et diaw moi j'aime
vraiment bien la tour ronde et 8,1
personnes fragiles biram est une tour en
face d'une dame un pion qui pousse à
mesure elle après je sais pas laquelle
j'aurais plutôt mis là oui j'aurais
vraiment mis là à sa part il a mis en 08
donc bon pourquoi pas ils surent suite
meilleur coup profondeur 26 44 ses
meilleurs coups 1 mais je sais pas
pourquoi d'autres bombes
pourquoi pas autour des 8 ça paraît
logique mais pour ces huit à deux badges
fait pas que c'était le truc de l'ordi
mais comme j'étais assez peut pas être
idiot de mètres la tour sur une colonne
ouverte
tu vises un peu ces deux les québécois
peuvent partir à un moment oui j'avais
vu le cavalier bkt je me rappelais que
ce n'était pas la ligne numéro un
alors tour à ses 8 h 5 le coup regardez
c'est quoi cavaliers prend h5 g300 de
vote soit taillé comme un fou je suis
pas sûr que ça sert à quoi j'adore le
coût de la turbine d'un f2 non mais tu
sais que c'est un coût souvent et
siciliennes surtout mais en gros heures
avec non mais c'est pas un coup à toi
même tu as dame la balle est fléché le
monde n'est pas un coup qui m'étonne je
suis pas là en mode avec deux jamais vu
mais j'aime bien je sais que ça paralyse
bien comme coût non-membre de la dame
des deux des blancs elle est chiante
fois qu'isabelle à bouger et à près de
13,5 et ça pourrait changer la donne
bref c'est un prix cazes data de detroit
mais détroit tut aixois qui boite sur
france 3 c'est pas faux on nous dit oui
c'est aline critique apparemment c'est
les coups qui donne envie puisque h4
enfin comme dirait vlad tu diras tu dis
mais ça fait h4 pour faire à chaque
phase on ne réussira pas à faire tu ne
réussira pas à faire j'ai quatre pour
jouer engagé 5 f 5 ça va être très
difficile organisé comme fab le disais
donc ta qali envie de commencer par h5
dévier ce cavalier faire g3 parce que
t'as pas le choix c'est pas que tu
restes de fer g3 surtout quand tu fais
ta maistre danone 3 d'année soit tu
menaces 3,5 peut-être aussi échangé à
les mater colonne h
ça c'est quand même ultra logique
ouais bah c'est compliqué tu veut
peut-être même fouache trois échanges et
les fous et faire j'ai quatre
ouais je pensais peut-être tu peux faire
c'est des fois je crois que tous soient
pas touchés avec les noirs ami tu vas
sera peut-être quand même fou
progressistes ufp ranger 4 et écrit un
truc en l'air ou quelqu'un saute en
l'air ce qui est du public ou qu'on est
là bas pas cette fois deux étudiants
très peu hein c'est pas comme s'ils
avaient des milliers de personnes qui se
déplacent et ses boutons sont ces packs
guichets fermés
c'est pas geoffrey guichard mais non ce
que je ressens et patrick non plus à une
petite centaine de personnes
habituellement way est peut-être un truc
comme ça
j'aimerais voir un petit coup d autres
voir ce qu'ils font on r'met en petite
caméra
ce sont ces que sacha il va afficher un
bon petit moment mais pau où là y'a plus
rien j'ai bien réussi à faire nul on
n'est pas c'est nul comme prévu et qui
rigail oui c'est un passé non plus serco
poser aussi s'arrête sur la frb quatre à
quatre matchs ça n'a contredit que ça
peut être très dangereux c'est le ding
qu'on voit depuis quelques jours non
mais c'est bien guéri qu'ils fassent ça
va il prend sa chance après l'hyper
suaire et pinera pas les candidats puis
c'est tout et puis mes bâtons quand tu
dois gagner bien prendre un petit risque
ou faire un truc intéressant les par
curiosité le spécial elle songe et 5 me
tiens une vente à ça c'était pas une
partie noël mamère victoire de mal mais
à paris c'est pas mettre ce truc g5
il ya une vieille partie
de guelph en barrière dessus en fait que
je trouve pas mal pour les blancs pour
le plan c'est à dire que tu te prends
pas trop la tête quoi avec le plan et
c'est de vite mettre un kényan de 3 tu
la tiens je peux aller vers 5 h un repas
on avait un peu analysé ensemble en plus
dans la partie de manu peut-être qu'on
l'avait regardé ensemble chez nous on
est fait sur la chanson la fsu régiment
l'avez pas lu en direct aussi ensemble
peut-être la fonte directe essence et a
rapidement restauré sa grande histoire
rapide très bien et d'ailleurs maxime
avait une chance à un moment donné deux
parties s'est pas bien passé dans
maximois bakou moi j'aime bien les
blancs on verra le spécial joue très
vite mais alex enhco comme d'hab qui
réfléchit longtemps d'accord donc
pourquoi bongo s'appelle le spécial
s'évade qui a mené ce surnom ce qui peut
jouer découvre très spéciaux parce que
comme disait vlad
il est capable du meilleur comme du pire
sur truc mais il est capable de coups
extraordinaires comme de coup
complètement qui vont à l'encontre de
table et donc spécial parce que tu fais
pas trop le mettre dans une case
on nous demande est ce que ça donnait ça
sent plus de faim déjà organes pas le
cavalier puis en plus on a de l'eiblen
hamel de setup keaven avec cette dame
tour ses deux patries sur la colonne h
qui s'en prend pas aux purges satanas
matin ce serait complètement fini
directement trop dangereux y adjoignent
ouais mais c'est ok bah ils rendent en
ligne chaude mais
puis on prend je pense qu'on regarde
même pas non mais si on regarde par
instinct cavaliers prend j'ai trois
points logique car il ya aussi g41 qui
vous prend il faut h 3o
bon je dois la prendre au sérieux mais
en fait je suis ton jeu fera tueur mais
n'aura pu trouver deux d'or deux virages
suite de danses possible ça se regarde
y'a quand même des 600 l'air encore il
ya la diagonale qui va s'ouvrir il ya le
doute et tour tu te conseillera détour
examen tour gérer et jeux sur la grande
diagonale franchement ça se regarde
aussi n'est ce pas c'était pas mon
option numéro un mais c'est une option
là tiens c'est bizarre je regrette ou
qui jouent h5 tu sais pertinemment que
le prochain coup c'est qu'elle prend h5
reste assis en fait j'ai connu fin j'ai
fumé pendant un moment ça fait plusieurs
années que je fume plus mais en fait tu
sais que le combat va arriver tu ça va
être chaud peut-être pendant une heure
ou deux tu pourra plus faire parce que
bat et là et tu as pu le temps et donc
tu dis ok c'est en larmes au moment où
je vais bien profiter de ma cigarette et
bien fumer bien goudronnées quoi et
après bien perdre à l'oxygénation là
pour bien me fatiguer avant le moment le
plus important de la partie
donc c'est donc un vrai sens mais c'est
un problème de grogne quoi faites fin du
sag et c'est maintenant ou jamais que
j'ai fumé ben tu préfères fumée et
perdre trois minutes ou 5 peu importe
que peut-être que je ne pourrai plus le
faire après la partie ils avaient donc
oui c'est pour ça qu'il a je pense un
vase
sinon bah sinon c'est pour toi là tu
sais d'autres options mais si juste ça
va aller pour se balader je pense pas
jamar campagne pour bien baissé mon
espérance de vie
pour maxime qui réfléchit quand il va le
prendre ce pion sur sa part est
obligatoire sinon les blancs ont fait
rage et attaquer le fou ce qui peut
encore connaître quelque chose puisque
en vrai bah je dirais que oui
est fiat clair c'est qu'ils savaient
qu'ils voient cette variante parce que
may cry me katz et cinq des six bombes à
s'affronter sur un mille pour cent
bon bah tu sais que j'ai six watches
c'est le truc et noir doivent faire tata
nouveauté qui avaient lieu deux tu sais
que tu as cette position est a priori vu
que maxime a joué vite c'est qui connaît
le truc est donc que l'ordi dois te dire
de faire ça en fait
en fait à pied deux peuvent encore
connaître rappeler mais déjà avoir vu la
position et amaigri au dessus que si
c'est pas par coeur je m'en bas et que
maxime est de vagues souvenirs ça je
comprends aussi parce que c'est à
réviser il ya dix jours battus c'est à
peu près ce qui se passe mais tu dois
quand même dire variant depuis les
fichiers c'est pas juste il ya cette
ligne il ya celle là il ya celle là est
celle là il ya la g3 ya g40 bien y'a pas
robien enfin moment en bon tu sais plus
trop tout se ressemble
mais tata unis de la position mais
quelque chose pour le coup lui ça c'est
straightforward quoi écoles fou aussi ce
qui pouvait être un oui mais en fait il
a vite donc c'est pas moi je veux dire
enfin
dire à ben j'aurais été la place de
grille tout problème en jeu connaître
encore la position
c'est à dire qu'en fait cette vente là
je leur a préparé en amont des candidats
donc évidemment je regardais un peu tous
les secteurs possibles qui se pose est
que font g4 et que font aussi ce avec
lequel un g4 et tous les machins dont
j'aurai tout dans l'ordi j'aurai le
fichier bonjour à réviser un peu en
tournoi et puis le matin de la partie où
je dois le jouer c'est clair que tu
révises combien de temps le matin avant
ben je vais faire deux trois heures mais
moi souvent je fais plus de mal
heureusement j'ai pas des fichiers de
ouf donc en fait je dois trouver le truc
le matin donc c'est ça le problème quoi
vous n'a pas toutes les variantes a déjà
en fait de moi le temps je me décide à
ce que je vais jouer il s'est déjà passé
hier s'est déjà passé du temps quoi je
regarde les parties du mec qui vient
peut-être faire ça ou ça un an tu
arrêtes ton choix you qui est bon je
vais faire ça bon bref où on retrouve
les coupes
donc ça peut être très long mais la
nature a ses bizarreries juke ifa il
fait h 4 h 5
le h5 laiseka hors cac et prend la 5ème
session nice mais il a bien sa décision
il sait bien qu'elle khouya prévu après
acheter avec ça c'est un truc j'arrive
pas à comprendre
toi tu crois non mais ça vraiment c'est
un truc j'ai du mal à comprendre
non mais tu aimes bien ça te rassure tu
revois surtout que tu sais que la
gratuité aux ici ça ou pas ouais je vous
jamais été un coup temp occasion moi je
faisais pas trop ça tu vas aller par
contre si si si si je savais que c'était
cinq épreuves 100 kg mon deuxième couche
de jouer quasiment tempo normalement par
contre si pas quasiment tempo je croyais
30 secondes ou une minute s'il passe un
quart d'heure je comprendrais pas trois
quatre minutes
toiture vérifie tout en fait tu sais que
tu as peut-être plus d'options tu sais
que ta g 4 points je savais pas de base
pour n'arriver que c'est pas con ou
alors ta tête joue à cinq points en dix
ans après qu'un proche 5 gss hakim pays
où il ya un an je comprends mieux
d'accord homme clé des 57 4 5 6 options
à six usagers g3 g4 qui est des cinq
mois je sais pas trop ce que dame reste
une option
en fait pourquoi ce rappel
skype rav4 on aimerait bien faire pas du
tout une fois je suis sans la voilà et
le deuxième arrière daniel pierrick fou
prend on apprenne de l'esu faire ça non
plus surtout qu'à mon avis c'est de pas
très évident à mach 4 dames g5 qui
menace d'un même si son aveu cavaliers
plat donc
donc en fait le pion au f4 et taboo bois
peinte à vous prendre du plomb mais
après bac estion est-ce qu'on est si
content d'ouvrir le bal après on peut
dire oui de la colle match même cavalier
en 5
ça va être assez sympa je vais pour les
blancs rivera retour proche cinq
épreuves
katia beaucoup de pièces qui convergent
pour après ça peut être complexe donc
oui il ya d'amr aussi dans les coups
possibles sont le japon c'est génial
qu'on a meublé pour une demi heure au
rush sans cuivre avec g3 direct la suite
la plus logique
non mais je pense que ça je pense qu'il
sait mémorial des rêves de là on a dit
complètement dans les rues pour maxime
je sais pas s'ils étaient bons élèves
dont l'avait dit mais on ne savait pas
dans mon en sais rien mais je trouve
chance au coût de 9,2 dans ce type de
position j'aime toujours ce coup là on
l'utilisé c'est un coup thématiques et
je suis impression sept blocs tes pièces
relouer mais bon faut h3 faut prendre
tout reprend mais du coup je te
contourne un peu ta da mais je veux le
tour et peut-être ses qualités 1 qui
avait lieu 3 après pour la chasse et
j'arrive pas
à voir si je suis content de l'ouverture
ou si je suis inquiet je suis mélangé
entre les deux émotions
non mais tu on est content mais après ça
veut dire qu'on a gagné parce qu'en des
condors on est content parce que c'est
un type de position qui sienne en loin à
maxime
donc il est dans son élément
ça c'est pas mal tu vois je préfère voir
ça qu'une finale de benfeld avec un
cadre à 5 quoi j'ai presque tendance à
ce moment-là de jeu ça pourrait être
aussi donc c'est de ce côté là c'est
quand même cool
après par un effet rebond de la grille
de chou qui sait pas c'est pas un
charlot donc tout est possible mais il
ya toutes les chances possibles
c'est une partie un peu tout est
possible une partie à trois résultats à
l'échelle 1 elle est très chaude salamon
fab et guéric qui continue à se promener
derrière il n'arrêtera donc jamais mais
il rodin vraiment c'est trop tôt tour
quoi enfants des heures tu le vois il
tourne autour de toi comme les gars
beyoncé qui volent n'arrête jamais
autour nitoo oni nitoo oni tour ça
qu'ils savent c'est un gars bien en fait
ouais il y tourne c'est marrant ce qui
fait il tourne dieu la ligue est
ouais c'est un vrai c'est un genre de
gabian incroyants
charland vraiment lui mettre un une
montre pour sarkozy une démarche
il marche et il a je pense qu'il dépasse
les 10 km de pare parti radical c'est
des vrais questions vous en conférence
de presse qu'il analyse saga des plus
précis où on voit qu'on met à marcher
quoi surtout les pompes de
dimanche soir alors on sait ici un peu
du beau monde je suis pas si gens auront
le temps de marcher déjà pour le terrain
ça va quand même inquiétant je crois que
je crois qu'il ya pas de bol qui jouera
un peu de bol quand il jouait pas du
coup on a les couilles la chance c'est
sympa mais si je pense qu'on va arriver
toutes les parties pas de bol en fait
beau la france on aime bien son combat
micro bomba latina cry on va être très
heureux le jour de tft ah bah oui j'ai
trois avec un champion d'europe de tft
rien au football dans le il a amélioré
allez on est très heureux namur petit
bol peut être initiée quoi serez vous en
mesure de pas de bol ce serait
magnifique le mur de pas de bol qui
signe ici voilà tant voir tourner en
grande calmes parce qu'on a vraiment
fait le tour de la position voilà la
bosse aux dépens de maxim mais car on
vous le disait a pas vraiment de passer
vraiment que du jeu dynamique du coup
par coup et le plan h 4 h 5 pour rire
oui tu l'avais dit mais pourquoi je
trouve que ça t'a rien accompli un bon
mois tu as ouvert c'est bien non mais
la suite la menace des blancs saison de
coups de fil à jouer s'il faisait de
frêche 3 le truc c'est que normalement
le fouillis pourrait aller en g4 bloqué
mais du coup tordu cahier des 5
parce que comme le gaillard h5 on avait
quand même parler de ça depuis tout à
l'heure ils mettaient pression sur l'a86
oui bon bailly plein bouquet ses trois
métiers la province il son correspondant
voilà en quelque sorte le cavaly m6 est
au marquage du carré d as c'est pour
faire ça
et donc maintenant qu'il est parti bombe
à un petit caïd et 5 peut tomber et du
couffo prend pions prendre des clichés
et c6 a atterri aux cinq ans leur ont
tendu mais bon évidemment de californie
en bep cap taxés deux donc c'est très
très très concret pas cette pression que
je préfèrerais jouer avec les blancs
très honnêtement mais ça veut rien dire
maxime il est tellement fort a joué à
kirby cris de joie qui avait quatre noms
mais en fait c'est juste logique de
tours ce but oui si tu as fait tu fais
est en plus une logique ex raconte c'est
que le christ au marquage du calice et 3
tu te barres tum un nouveau mais commet
au marquage à la culotte quoi mais je
préfère les blancs ici quand même ça
m'inquiète
cette idée g4 g5 avec le four b2 juste
l'impression que pour le prix d'un pion
les blancs ont tellement d'avancé sur
leurs attaques et les pièces noires moi
j'aime pas ses cavaliers au québec a dit
pas si mal non
5 je comprends que vous au maximum nuit
jubile j'ai un cadrage 5 je suis là
c'est pas masquer en b quatre pays les
poké il est utile mais je trouve les
pièces blanches vont s'organiser quand
même beaucoup plus rapidement et
beaucoup plus harmonieusement eux qui
attaquent en premier quand même un bel
horizon donné un pion ce privilège quoi
ça va être catastrophique surtout comme
tu le disais ils ont le fait que les
blancs semblent encore être en leur
prépa temps à dire que la position
encore correcte puisque si c'était déjà
foutu c'est plus dans sa prépa les dents
à plus de 1200 ils devraient réfléchir
pour trouver peu un peu ce que caruana
raté contre maxime sa fille l'a pas fait
le tour à sept là du coup maxime pour
mon jeu vous les bons coups donc la
position doit être correct mais j'ai
l'impression qu'elle se joue mieux avec
les bleus
bon déjà tu peux récupérer ton pions des
6e et peut-être que tu as du tour a
changé 4 qui tombe avec le four b2 ça me
fait hyper peur en fait ma position
après j'ai très confiance en maxime si
maxime on retrouve son niveau de jeu il
va la gagner
par contre si on a le maximum des
premières rondes ça peut être dur mais
s'est montré très intéressante un ski et
ses trois hommes prendre quatre on nous
dit de dépôt est en train de gagner
ah bon waouh bon sens incroyable
commence à s'entraîner tous les
certificats pour n'importe quoi drôle
chat non mais je serais étonné qu'il n'y
ait pas et mieux mais pas du tout enfin
c'est juste nul
oui c'est nul mais bon ils vont être un
pion à ça tu vas tomber tes deux ou
trois rien mais je comprends qu'ils
envoient avec leur design plus un
messager réfléchirai même pas en fait
avec les noirs enfin pour ses sets je
sais pas quel point tu veux faire avec
les blancs mais bon tu en prends la
masse mais je veux dire tu peux faire
tomber 6 on dira tu doubles sur 1 là bas
at on bien pour ses 7 me tombait 6
blancs et ses drames et leurs droits
mais bon ça c'est complètement nul
oui non mais tu vas bientôt le détour
sur a7 et puis bien sûr été pour le
lancer d'amener le roi tout là bas alors
sacrifieront les jeux ça c'est pas juste
une simple je pense que oui mais je leur
dis qu'est-ce qu'il a peut-être qu'ils
pensent qu'ils perdaient 3 b 5
pour à 500 ma tantie nepeut gagne ça
c'est une prépa johnny et je veux revoir
parce que ça j'ai jamais vu en fait mais
ça peut être une prépa mais mon vrai
c'est juste complètement égal l'option
ce que ça viendrait juste abusé
aurais-tu partagé entre les vals de
l'ordi et ce plan j'ai envie de dire à
la compliquent a pas d'autre mot et le
fait qu'avec les noirs j'y réfléchirai
même pas avec j'attendrai que make me
serre la main en face non mais le
problème via un pion de trop et loire et
b4 qui pourrait me c'était le coup ils
me rendent leur dire de la part de
maxime
en tout cas n'est pour ce que je viens
excellent pour lui la partie pierre
coffin ce prolongement nuls ont
peut-être l'autre des formats la matière
j'ai gagné cadeau non mais là les héros
est excellente mais caruana a mal joué
c'est pas possible je peux pas croire
encore
san jose c'est tellement pas dangereux
fait hier en algérie veut juste faire
nul rapide je vais arriver au 40e c'est
ce truc là dont on a parlé déjà le mec
tu sais n'est pas là n'est pas le faire
je veux tout tempo ni haschich vous tous
tempo bien ça à faire annuler tiens
regarde sympa d'avoir sainton magie d'un
pion à passer je suis mieux parce que je
veux dire sortie on rentre on rentre à
l'hôtel à 14h30
il ya des nouveaux sifflets des scènes
chaotiques en fait non le clin d'oeil
autre chose pour toi ça ressemble un peu
à ça tu as caruana qui a juste envoyé un
peu les coûts mais bon bah je veux moi
je resterai quand même sur évolution
plutôt d'une non mais ça doit être nul
mais maintenant devoir défendre en fait
donc et le cavalier b4 comme on disait
le cavalier beckham qui vient remplir le
rôle du cavaly m6 qui est parti donc et
contrôler la classe g 5 pour éviter
qu'il y ait des 5 qui serait gênant
s'attaquerait la dame et saint et ça
ouvrirait le fou donc oui l'accueil des
5 bat doublement pas bien parce qu'on
colle bien à gaz des cinq puis assez
d'eau qui saute donc dans sa foi je
crois oui c'est logique après peut-être
d'autres mais fou j'ai deux je pensais
fou g4 presque
retour h4 vous prend 1,2 si tu as les
promelles genre c-26 dame prend équipes
rangées trois tacles adam suite vous
prenez fiacre à moins qu'ils aient un
claque de qualité ou quoi mais ça a
l'air un peu too much
ce qui est beau c'est que les deux sont
encore sûrement dans leur prépare bon ok
si c'est comme ça se produit parce que
après tout je dois besoin truc perdant
non plus non et puis c'est donc
impossible
ça défend bien des deux côtés ça fait
nul à genève à la fois je crois f5 on
n'aime pas moi j'aime pas on m'a
toujours appris de pacho option droit
qu'on veut attaquer c'est l'action
prenait 5 vous prend vous prend scipion
probable cheval en l'air c'est tout
reprend 4 pas très convaincant
non mais même tu vois il y aurait pas g4
city juste ouvert là pour rien j'aurais
jamais faire je n'aurais jamais fait fab
sinon c'est une petite pub ben j'ai mis
6 3 minutes de pub ouais je fais une
petite pause en tant que la pub vas-y
vas-y femmes familles et la pause pub
du coup les gens n'ont rien raté favé
parti ça va ouais donc ce cavalier
bécasse il en a joué par maxime
apparemment comme on le disait à
l'instant ça semble être à chaque fois
les meilleurs coups je voulais parler de
joueurs donc il est possible même
probable qu'au moins l'un des deux soit
encore dans sa prépa côté gris tuque le
fait qu'ils réfléchissent au temps n'est
pas forcément étonnant il et il est
vraiment capable de juste passer son
temps à bien se remémorer par plaisir il
est un peu un peu fantasque dans sa
manière d'utiliser son temps comme on
l'a dit l'idée des blancs ça va être
d'ouvrir le
l'ale les droits dont ils ont déjà
commencé à l'ouvrir il a critiqué a
réussi à ouvrir sa colonne hp pour le
moment elle est obstruée par les pièces
noires notamment ce cavalier h 5 1 qui
bloquent l'action de la tourache 1 et
donc c'est pour ça qu'on regarde ce coup
fourrage 3 pour les blancs l'idée de
développer leur dernière pièce et
préparer un g4 donc après fou proches
trois tours prend h3 on avait regardé un
peu plus tôt d'un f2 donc pour venir se
placer et sur g4 envoyé peut-être un fou
prend f4 et cette dame en f2 ici est
très utile puisque après cavaliers pros
f4 on aurait dame prend des deux
échanges les dames tout reprend d2 et
qui avait les pros f4 et ça ce sera un
cas de figure intéressant pour maxime
puisque les blancs auraient encore un
petit peu d' attaque mais aurait encore
un petit peu d'attaqué maxime à deux
puis aurait deux pions plus ici et il
n'y aurait plus les dames sur
l'échiquier donc ce serait très peu
dangereux on pourrait jouer juste crois
j'essais tourache 8 et défendre ce pion
h7 entre autres un à beaucoup d'autres
choix donc ça ça se passerait plutôt
bien pour maxime
donc après ce drame f2 peut-être que les
blancs voudrait jouer tour dh 1 pour
doubler le long de la colonne h et là la
position est simplement très complexe
les blancs ont pourri des jouets
peut-être tour h2o cavaliers d1 pour
chasser la dame de f2 et enchaîner par
g4s que ça va passer ou pas ça c'est une
autre une autre question les amis mais
ça semble être une position critique est
complexe et on voit que le coutour c8
peut servir ici sur des cavaliers des
uns à avoir des tours prend ses deux
dents certains monde
c'est une position très compliqué à
double tranchant
on va voir un c'est pour moi la ligne la
plus directe elle a plu au principal
entre guillemets après il doit y avoir
d'autres points bref femmes c'est quand
même très logique 1 fois je crois parce
que surtout j'adore je pense qu adam eve
ii qui peut être pénible attaque le fou
et on n'a pas foulé f3 on va devoir le x
h 3 mais ça aucun intérêt d'art juif ou
g2 pour chaque fois je crois puisque de
toute façon les noirs voulait jouer
d'ahmed deux fois je crois
en être quasiment le papa l'unique coup
mais de très loin le coup de plus
logique
on va vous
un tour h4
bizarre après ça peut être une
possibilité
possibilité mais je n'aime pas trop la
tête du cou j'aime pas le fait que ce
fait ce four est en f1 pour les blancs
parce qu'on aura besoin de le bouger
pour amener la tour en h1 éventuellement
et on a besoin de développer nos pièces
donc ça c'est pas le coup qui m'a qui
m'attire le plus d'un prend des six on a
vu qu'il ya des idées à base de cavale
et c6 ici maintenant qu'à la tour
ensuite on avait même tour c'est si ce
qui peut être intéressant
un père dame prend 1,5 et ça ça peut
être aussi à calculer fou j'ai cette
dame des cinq pour échanger les dames et
d'un rêve de en choeur il a joué
3 c'était le coup et le coût attendu
mais je faisais un petit un petit résumé
de de tous les coups possibles fab fo h3
et t2 loin même de très très loin le
coup le plus logique et c'est le coup
qui a été joué un par le joueur russe
et ben non on s'attend à foug proches
trois tampons h3 et d'amener bien cette
dame à f2 mais à notre question est-ce
qu'ils ont des objectifs ou proches
trois bonjour soient leurs menaces m'en
fou prend ici c'est peut-être et dame
prend des systèmes de commencer un
double autour de 6 ouais alors dit
propre aux sources et 6 du coup les
dames quelques parts de quoi est-ce
qu'on peut décrire la dame déjà que les
blancs un truc j'aimerais bien faire si
je peux et si on peut pas c'est
exceptionnel dans les jardins meurs tu
les prends ces deux dans le tronc sa
rodin ça redonne donc oui la dame
attaché à savon des machins débile
hockey dans fois je crois pour ces six
bons aussi ça c'est le coup même logique
priori je comprends mais c'est très
possible que maxime connaissent d'où
l'idée d'aller si à tour la fuite en
fuite oui et tu presses f4 un peu et
surtout ses tons purs ou 5 disparaître
on attend un deuxième qui vient
remplacer
de plus en plus si les deux connaissent
pas encore c'est beau c'est beau un tour
sur f1 c'est la logique des champions
c'est tellement dur de juger la position
à ce moment un jour quand tu crois
peut-être je demeure non y'a plus les
cahiers français de oui mais un cap lui
faut aussi s'il a plus le problème de
carélie ces deux dames prend b3 unclear
c'est une possibilité et ours et 6 froid
je crois d'un rêve de en est une autre
mais j'aime mieux tout racisme je suis
très content de favre prend 2,6 de marie
matte aurait fui d'avoir des défenseurs
septième rangée sais pas je me sens
beaucoup mieux franchement de tout
reproche
3 je trouve ça inquiétant mais bon
week-end de rien mais le deuxième tour
qui arrive les 500 h5 la dame qui s'en
va les f-5 les g4 de partir en faisons
tous et 6 alors je pense pourquoi pas on
rejette
tu tiens de surf sur les peaux à bien me
latour en b 6 bref quand même pas à
comprendre dans quel monde
il ya une chanson en dur mais j'ai quand
même faire attention avec les noirs un
petit peu on va dire que vous comparez
retour un damné le pion la tour noire
devant le pion déjà les mieux bien
d'autres avec les blancs et la tour un
v6 qui coûte cher au roi bon sénat élu
pour la coupure au visage mais voilà il
va conserver son royaume va faire tour
céda ouais je me tourne megan il se
plaît de geri on nous dit bosch a vu
comme ça c'est l'heure normale
peut-être qu'il a raté un coup avant
garde à vue on a eu après 12 c3 il s'en
est servi pour faire b 4 ya une bonne
position il ya un mois je trouve que
c'est normal on retourne sur maxime
c'est un faux
ouais façon voulait faire le tour donc
ça nous a pas trop déranger non non bien
sûr
or c'est important de faire un tour plus
qu'au début du tournoi maintenant mon
détails mais on veut savoir un peu ce
que font les adversaires directs des
prétendants à la callas pour l'appel la
partie n'est peu caruana elle est
vraiment importante pour maxime parce
que siné peau gagne la victoire
aujourd'hui est vraiment obligatoire en
fait je dois déjà fait rollin' de 3,1
points et demi tu rattrapera pas
prennent que même un truc c'est que
c'est fait c'est fait tu peux pas faire
plus solides ou moins un point de
pression à ce qu'elle aime bien sûr et
qu'est ce que je veux dire ya ka et
guéri aussi c'est important il sait
aussi s'ils gagnent avec les blancs là
il se remet vraiment bien mais bien dans
les grilles cherche à gagner les jeux
une partie pour gagner et on verra s'il
y arrive ça c'est deux choses
différentes
vouloir et pouvoir déjà la volonté est
là les recomposer là une belle position
à nice 1-2 de combat maxime aussi gris
chucky ferme pas le jeu comme on l'avait
prévu
comme on l'avait prédit on avait
toujours su on a déçu
moi j'ai pas toujours suivre jésus
t'aime ça valait le messenger de vlad
oui la musique j'ai su me bats pour ça
je savais pas mais avant ça non mais
après tu as toujours su que j'ai
toujours le message de vlad en disait
beaucoup on disait long il a toujours
dit non mais tu envoies et envoya
soldate de piazza c'était sûr c'est
obligé on montre qu'on les envie de
graphiques gens ne triche pas on trouve
en thèse retire ces prépas aux relire ce
retour n'est pas déjà tu passes le gars
est donc belle way exactement
nota pas de trucs électrique sur toi
t'as pas de téléphone tapas de merde je
sais pas quoi déjà on a vu une belle
partie de la triche
après re lire tes notes bâché bas et pas
dans les sous doués ou tu as détruit
dans tes chaussures et machin mais bon
il ya eu d
histoire oui madonna qui se barre est
quand un marchand total mais la même
avec des bacs c'est enfin bon voilà on
va papa mais yahia il ya eu des
histoires là tout le monde mais en fait
le vrai problème de la triche c'est
l'écho assisté par l'ordi regardez prépa
c'est de la triche aussi mais si je
devais et quantifier le degré de trucs
ça serait moins grave en fait en gros tu
joues un coup tu es censé connaître
oui mais bon oui mais on l'a oublié que
c'est de la triche
tu m'as est autant d'exclus si jamais
mais le truc qui rend infernale s'est
joué les coups de l'ordi cela tu deviens
champion mais bon tant rire oui mais
dans tous les cas ça devrait être bon
terme à la nommer dessus mais il a été
déjoué et quantifier les dires des ja
qui est pas de tes pas accès à un
téléphone un ordi ou quoi ok déjà c'est
le gros du boulot de fait ouais pour
faire simple si jamais je joue bien moi
qu'on dirait bien que c'est pas jouer
aux échecs et qui là que ça leur dit va
quand même me battre et il abolir tout
ce qu'il veut je veillais bon bah je
vous dis je quantifie le brave tu peux
continuer pas moi je veux dire la
quantification est très simple fab tu
donnes n'était pas très fin mais oui je
te dis pas que je les défensives mais
bon on va arrêter on va sortir des
blagues
non mais tu sais qu'il ya un tacle qui
peut partir donc on va on va on est
d'accord même toi tu as envie d'envoyer
un tacle on a tous les deux très envie
d'envoyer on va on va zapper les tacles
mais on est très chaud donc du coup on
se remet en grande calmes on revoir de
max en fait s'il ya un secret dans les
live
quand tu commences cette somme c'est un
peu à monter en pression tu regardes
maxime et ut merveille et tu deviens dun
ouais non regarde j'ai pu lire
d'ailleurs dans des dents des sur
twitter que les tibétains dans les dents
lemoine haddou les moines tibétains pour
leur méditation se concentrer sur maxime
avec la cas où une photo qui non non non
ils connaissent maximum bien évidemment
donc ils ont voilà ils ont ils ont vu
maxime y connaissent maxime et tu vois
quand il se pose comme ça et qu'ils
rentrent dans une dans une longue
méditation pour garder tu vois cette
cette puissance de concentration et ne
plus être dérangé pas rien ce sur quoi
il se concentrer sur maxime en fait les
deux bouts wulf où il avoue fait le
fourrage français votent pour ceux ci si
si il va faire et des rêves de toronto
en retour prouve
peut-être une petite demi heure tu sens
le calme tu sens le bel et bien fait la
sérénité en toi tu sens que tout d'abord
maxime est habillé en blanc voilà je
vous aime bien le fou ok donc ça libère
le cavalier un peu de ces îles alors à
dubaï a plus le fou derrière et donc là
plusieurs options pour griller juke tour
dh 1 paraît pas qu'on bon doublé tour à
noter que l'idée c'est sur gk qu'on l'a
pas dire mais c'est de pouvoir bouger
alors là tu l'as dit mais on n'a pas
montré très bon vous êtes quand même ça
c'est dommage deux séchoirs van damme
age 2 tonnes je suis vraiment 4 pas de
bulle de faire qualifier sont montrés g5
tu reviens tu voulais garde arabe ajoute
accélérer le mouvement
ag 5.5 proche des 5 peut être le favori
notre got talent heures un peu way you
when she wolf 6h 7,3 g 7
moi je suis tu vois moi j'essaie
tourache 8 me tue
tendu mais bon d'un beau mur de deux
pions devant toi bien bien bien un mur
de brp quelqu'un mb ap auquel vont
prouver ambitions deuxième option si
kiev 6 pour ça qu'on veut aussi faire
d'un provincial pour repartir annonçait
la fin semble un peu tendue aux cayes
fcg 5th 5
tu sais que ça ça me fait peur ouais tf6
fenêtre moi je réussisse avec les normes
je peux voir complexe complexe comble
peut-être les noirs mais date on n'a pas
la qualité de l'air est en fait juste f5
bien oui oui est humaine sf six fois de
suite ça faut montrer parce que c'est
pas mal avec la goana ce rhume est le
fruit mûr et le fou est mort un cavalier
aux hotspots genre là je pense toujours
mais kg 3 doukaev 5-17 tout dommage de
tours h un homme prend on pas into two
jamais intérim tout ou quoi faire
maintenant et c'est un peu dans votre
saoul alors attends je veux dire du coup
j'ai 4 c c'est quoi
j'ai gardé en lui
le groupe g passe voulait montrer mais
c'est automatiquement ça jure 4g 4,5 et
6,5 m6 j'ai simplement c'était package
5,7 kg 4 fragil mocky turin de
fourchette
mais bon là j'aime pas le l'agencement
des pièces ne parle pas en fait je suis
tout à fait d'accord avec toi j'ai pas
envie de regarder 20 kg 4 non protégés
en b 4 comme tu disais il est bien et
mal place à la fois il est bien placé
les sur un trou mais baladeuses ont ils
font mieux que soi pour payet qui est
sûrement le meilleur tu sens que c'est
artificiel métier que j'aime pas les
noirs
si l'américain the gap c'est que ça
tourne pas rond great choc en tout cas
dubitatif un bon mais va du bit et
pendant un bon moment je pense prêt
maximal air confiant j'ai envie de lui
faire confiance
il a pas l'air inquiet maxime
s'échauffent outre g
autour de la chasse comme un coup mais
j'ai quatre maires vraiment pas qu'on se
moque épreuve classée direct en faire
les frais je suis sûr qu'il va faire
si tu veux faire est donc allé prendre
comprend alors je sais pas si moi je
reste le préfet d'arrêt dans nature tu
me l'as tout reprend dès 6 ans vrai tu
as tout rachat mais ça c'est un regret
pour le blond stora chances qu'un chien
est ce que tu sais que tout rachat h6 je
te claque à tout accord reach est quand
même affiche de faim je claque tout en
fait
et je me demande même si ya pas d monde
où je peux claqué en h7 faire tout
rachat qui a été sympa je sais pas je
commence à regarder ces trucs là même le
problème de ça en fait c'est peut-être
que c'est pas si grave tu peux défendre
mon trio to be l'idée de gagner avec les
nantais juste en pls et peut-être tu
fais un échange d'amendements 5 je peux
quoi regard animer un bal adam sandler
dit fait ça mais c'est bon j'ai ça c'est
genre en fait baisse scénario qu'elle
aille à tour français 3 pardon verano
mais bon tout tout tout le gagner quoi
les genres sa cb ce scénario oui mais
bon là j'ai abusé mais ces baisses
scénario est donc
donc c'est pas ça si ça après avoir si
riche elle encore dans sa prépa il
essaye encore de se rappeler après pas
grisha elle fait peur quand même pour un
peu connaître sacha il peut vraiment
temps que une heure en étendant sa prépa
à ces noms mais c'est possible même en
se rappelant donc là il essaye de se
rappeler fou g7 tu as ils essayent
encore de se remémorer son fichier il ne
se rappelle pas 26e coup non mais je
reviens pas bien apprendre mm pô 20e
coup et elle sera celle déjà plus d'une
petite sous variante us et king je ne
veux plus entraînés ce joueur très
faible vraiment beaucoup mieux les
petits de 14 ans du sein et successeur
crédible
non mais mais ça a l'air assez grave
non mais juste avec ce que vlad
entraînant des jeunes
donc ben
pas tellement logique j'ai les quatre
web à tour dh montant des achats tv5 ou
noir pour souffler alors qu'en belgique
a tu continues logique donc en plus
c'est un schéma de maths à tanger pas
comment je peux le faire marcher avant
je vais écouter bill est ok je suis un
coût des billets c'est que parfois tu te
prends même ce truc non mais moi ce qui
m'inquiète c'est que sacha j'ai
l'impression qu'il ya même pas encore
joué un seul coup de la partie aussi je
sais pas en fait je sais pas où va la
prépa ou elle s'arrêter non mais ce
visage de machin de ça tu tu essaies de
te rappeler
oui c'est clair quand tu regardes un peu
comme se regarde comme ça tu te poses
turf et ce à un an ils essayent de se
rappeler que j'ai eu le temps de
réflexion et que sa chasse aux saveurs
pas forcément dire une grand chose non
franchement
on n'est pas si beau petit allez la
france
elle affrontera la france je la perruque
un peu mais un peu la perruque fab four
retrouver du courage là c'est pas un
moment facile
les séances c'est tout ligne 1 ce serait
fou g7 en fait du coup le le plan un peu
de côté un bond de 9,2 soit non en fait
c'est peut-être pourquoi je crois que je
sens pas trop moi de [ __ ] j'ai point
fr près de trappes à tour ceci sans
détour c'est si c'est que pour n'importe
quoi mais bon on n'a pas trop parlé des
prépas dit rich ou que jusqu'à
maintenant parce qu'il fait pas partie
des îles fait plus partie des favoris
mais c'est vrai que c'est un joueur qui
est généralement très bien préparés
aussi à ceux qui aiment l'ombre de
velotte gré ou un loup solitaire mais
qui me choque moi le mien ce mur de
l'année la france mais met généralement
son point faible à sacha ça arrive à peu
près maintenant j'y réfléchis à fond il
peut vraiment mal joué
le raté des choses sacha bat maxime
l'avait battu d'ailleurs un petit peu
comme ça à riga sacha avait pris
l'avantagé ils étaient venus une très
bonne position et trois coups plus tard
il est au bord de la rupture
ouais donc la position est difficile
enfin difficile plus agréable à jouer
pour pour alexander mais le truc coincé
que j'ai 4 qui part ce qu'aime logique
qu'as tu te fais suer ouais non mais
voguer l'autre cologix autour des achats
de mission mais bon je ne vois pas de
contre indication à faire j'ai du temps
et de faire avec la main instante si tu
regardes dubos photos qui prouvent
quatre saveurs qui est fini je propose
un bien sûr que tu as tous rendaient en
plus elle est utile aussi dans certaines
rentes ai demandé si ce donc si tu peux
la garder en d1 un ou deux coups de plus
et faire ton plan de la même manière tu
le fais non ne sais pas
boss parra juste coulé sous le sens ce
coup j'ai quatre dames détroit n'est pas
un coup difficilement quoi peut-être
mais là on rappelle qu'avec les blancs
on était en galère avec ce courage
on voulait jouer des dames détroit des
dames 1 et là on a réussi côté côté
blanc à se débarrasser de ce clouage du
fou chantant un fou sans vraiment perdre
de tempo on dirait que on a donné le
plus rage fait le plus rage dans ces
structures dont tu as envie de donner
je veux te l'enlever toi même tu ferais
bien de quelque part les noirs ont
réussi à gagner un temps quoi les bleus
ont réussi à gagner un temps sur les
noirs le jeu des piqûres tu te tais
perruque
ouais ouais attends je fais juste un
petit tour rapide des stades n'est pas
pour ça va tenir sans trop de problème
mon haras on a suivi vrai quoi voilà ça
va être chaud ça va être chaud ou pas
mais oui enfin tout cas on sait pas trop
quoi dire
on n'a pas de favori de toute façon j'ai
envie de te dire fable là c'est vraiment
la partie de maxime qui est importante
estime parce que si maxime perd
aujourd'hui il aura toujours sa chance
sur mille six cent là comme reach ou
qu'en faisant 3 sur 3 mai à niveau
serait improbable très très improbable
ça passerait par trois victoires
consécutives les trois à la suite c'est
le 3 la suite ouais comme tu le dis
pourri tout
quatre à la suite ce sera le 3 la suite
je dis oui qui sera une condition
sinequanone à la moindre chance de se
qualifier donc maxime n'a plus le droit
à la défaite
un clignotant je te laisse deux minutes
fab
je prends le flambeau ça laisse le
flambeau je mets la petite pub au
passage devant lui ses appuis la bonne
heure
je reviens d'ailleurs de la pub a tout
de suite j'ai tout j'ai tout ce qu'il
faut j'ai l'échiquier g a souri j'ai ma
souris qui est très très efficace qui va
très vite
ben quoi le dernier coup de maxime ce
petit coup de fouet cette qui laisse un
peu le champ libre pour les blancs vont
peut-être faire ce g 4 ou tour h1 alors
on one music g4 c'était un peu le le
coup un peu un pénible s'est passé le
mot mais qui carrière logique pour
poursuivre le jeu quoi voilà on va voir
on va voir comment on vous dit ah les
autres partis en ce moment je vous fais
un mini tour des stades comme temps
avoir un passé hier le temps de gatwick
réfléchissent ce gris tchouk il peut
vraiment aboutir très très longtemps ici
donc on a cette partie entre le leader
n'est pas avec les blancs et caruana a
priori nul parce que ce pion vois pas
comment il peut aller plus loin et puis
bah le roi il aurait bien voulu venir
par là bas et des bas c'est un peu
bloqué par ici il pleure un coup comme
h4 prodi rabattue ne viendra pas là donc
bon je pense ça va faire nul hockey au
40e 1 au 32e coup 32e kouanda hui qu on
alexine qu en gros ça joue pas pour
grand chose dont ils jouent pour après
vu comme ça j'aime bien les blancs parce
que ses pions droit avant c'est bien
loin ça fait d'être ou un truc comme kf5
ça peut arriver à tout moment et donc ça
a l'air plutôt sympathique pour
l'extenso qui gagne cette partie c'est
vrai quand même deux victoires ce
tournoi ça serait beau passer quand même
vraiment le petit poucet de l'épreuve
est ok l'autre partie par entre
importante c'est celle là guiry guiry
contre dingli rennes et donc geek et
dans groupe des poursuivants comme
maxime ils sont un point de dépôt tout
cela et on y prend sa chance à vous
voyez s'est recomposé s'est tendue ces
shows à l'eiblen bas s'ils peuvent elles
ouvrent droit ouvrir la colonne b pour
pour s'engouffrer pour faire du à quatre
baies 5 pour peut-être prendre je sais
pas donc chaud les marrons chauds quoi
voilà et on va retourner sur la partie
qui nous intéresse le plus c'est
évidemment celle de maxime mai donc
c'est aux blancs de jouer donc on voit
un peu l'enjeu de la partie
c'est les noirs ou un pion de plus si
vous comptez aller nos rangs sept pions
les blancs dont six après la stout et
équilibrée donc avions de plus pour
maxime
mais c'est une position le matériel pour
l'instant ne compte pas tant que ça
parce que recomposée recomposée ça veut
dire que c'est la tac qui prime et le
pion qu'ils ont donnée blanc c'est le
pion de la colonne h qui va leur
permettre de mettre toutes les tours
dessus qu'elle soit pas bloquée par le
pion et de venir mettre la pression
donc c'est pour ça qu'on s'attend à un
petit g4 qui partent à tout moment quoi
et puis c'est chaud c'est chaud mais
ouais mais on peut avoir cette position
tous les yeux pour une bonne vingtaine
de minutes parce que bas comme je disais
creed choc basse et le kaki species
pourrait faire beaucoup beaucoup se
mettent très mal autant et puis après
tout enchaîné avec trente secondes et je
veux quand même très bien malgré tout
mais donc donc à voir mais si j'avais un
prono sur le coup à jouer ce serait agi
quatre quoi faire après g4 de monde je
suppose je sais pas en fait à deux
boissons de cavalli attaquer à partir de
là tu dois bien te vient faire un truc
ses terres soit tu prends ça tu recules
reculer sa part un peu bizarre tu te
reprends une deuxième vague
si tu te dis je suis très malin je
reviens je te bloque ou maya lui qui
arrive et c'est un peu la cata parce que
simplement as tu te tue tout enfermé bon
c'est la crise donc bas donc non tu fais
pas
et l'ordi disait peut-être kg 4 mais
c'est un truc qui semble vraiment pas
bien en fait il n'est pas protégé il un
peu là comme ça tout seul comme un idiot
on peut te faire un petit coup en
attaque
je sais pas si ça marche je serais très
surpris
bien sûr il ya des foyers des trucs
bizarres qui marche mais on essaie
païenne maximum on est sûr g4 il va il
va prendre à mon avis c'était ça l'idée
c'est à ramener le foot se déballe le
cas où le pion reprennent et d'ailleurs
on va voir le cas et ben en moins on n'a
pas lui qui brille et qui nous semble
être au soir des balles on a un en un
mec en face donc vu comme ça ça leur
logique juste ce qui peut paraître
logique pour les blancs c'est soit de
ramener la dame là bas soit de prendre
d'abord on pourquoi pas ça va ça attaque
ce pion sur la route en chemin et
peut-être tour h1 damage de et on
renvoie à l'artillerie lourde par ici
donc c'est quand même tendu semblerait
que la suggestion de l'ordi ce soit de
jouer vite dames 5 un peuple autres mais
bon on se débarrasse de la dame adverse
ça peut le faire mais bon c'est quand
même choquant surtout que les blancs
sont pas à 100 c'est échanger pour
échanger donc voilà la position de la
partie ici et là bas j'ai quatre jouer
j'ai quatre jours et il n'a pas réfléchi
50mm yeux de chacun eh ben on va voir
quelle est l'idée de maxi prend f4
circulent alors jouez vous demandez qui
se passe il laisse le cas et faire
manger bain une pièce de plus c'est
quand même un peu trop cher et le retour
de la france la france qui est de retour
et on va là c'est plutôt la russie 1
j'ai envie de te dire j'ai entendu quand
je revenais avec buvait un petit peu
d'eau qui avait le g4 qui est parti
assez vite de la part de guy ritchie est
ce inquiétant hungry choo qui est venu
pour faire sa partie est le message de
vlad inquiète de plus en plus ça devient
de plus en plus inquiétant pour pour
maxime la position des blancs comme
tulle expliqué brillamment fab beaucoup
plus facile à jouer un jeu facile à
jouer tous les pions
et les tours et avec l'or c'est ce qu'on
sait ce qu'on peut appeler une une
position à deux résultats quasiment en
tout cas en fait il ya que si nokia 6 kg
4 apparemment débile va bien oui mais
bon je veux dire je regardais même pas
enfin ça pique les yeux mais mais bon
bah si ça marche ça marche des fois tu
faire mais mais si c'est ça l'idée est
que c'est ça
on va jouer kfc suspense il n'est pas un
papa parti le parti pour manger un truc
non pas je crois pas parce qu'il prend
le train quand tu manges tu as plutôt
une prise comme nom et une prise lors du
placement est gratuite et une prise plus
ouvertes - les prises ouvertes là non on
va voir on va se mettre
directement mais pour le coup en plus kg
4 ça peut être une conception à la
maxime qu'en sais tu mets un peu des
pires c'est compliqué pape sy maxime
veut gagner que ces candidats il faut
qu'ils jouent des koalas maxime ça c'est
le genre de coup il ya que lui qui peut
le trouver il ya qu'il ya que lui et
n'est peut-être au monde capable de
faire ça mais je pensais plus tu maxime
mais oui car edf selon le fumeux roscoff
fab
après pour scorer les amis encore
poursuivre par kg 4 on est de retour
voilà ce génie on a douté à on a douté
désolé les gars n'a douté de maxime
pendant quelques instants
mais il nous fait mentir il a trouvé le
cavalier six cavaliers g4 a great choc w
[Rires]
mais les forains et voilà c'est quand il
joue comme ça à maxime qu'il est très
dangereux fabien c'est le maxime sion le
tao shi qui arrive ça c'est le maxime
s'est laissé le grand maxime concon ac
on est peut-être en train de retrouver
aujourd'hui à fab
ou alors c'est la fusée se déclenche et
oui et guiry qui vient faire des siennes
il dérange gris tchouk regard et gris
tout ça ça y est la maxime il fait très
très mal il a fait mal avec ce cavalier
f6 et regarde position de marloux çi ça
y est faye et les amis la fusée lancée
mise en orbite imminente sur les coups
de 6 heures quand même ça a duré
quelques heures encore fab les cinq
joueurs est sain il regarde le cavalier
g4 qui va partir le cavalier g4 qui va
partir guichou qui se relève il ne l'a
pas vu y pense que ces cafouillages 5
d'un maquillage 5 c'est vrai mais il
pense que ces caches non mais t'as une
des émotions sais tu ce que veut dire le
4 août si tu avais ces deux tu fais des
trucs chelous mais c'est carré léger
quatre femmes moi je pense son cinquième
essai carige et quatre femmes terrible
maxime qui aura du très lourd ici c'est
un truc où tu peux pas toucher mais bon
ça leur belle rejoint qui rejoint thomas
pesquet après ses idées de l'ordre de
base donc je vais voir que ça se fait de
meilleur
il va le faire là il est parti pour le
quadrillage et quattro un piège 5e 5 je
peux pas faire et prend le catch est
prévu quatre je pense juste ça marche
pas wright est bas du cou ouais c'est
qu'eric g4 les amis alors fou et je
n'aurais jamais eu le problème en fait
c'est même la réflexion l'emmène fanta
stock options l'avons pourquoi pas mais
seedorf et rouge et 7 pour en faire son
travail c'est sûr qu'il a fait je
n'aurais jamais fait non plus pour ça
qu'on commente un nom mais regarde il a
quoi c'est ça incroyable qu'est ce qu'il
est fort en quart kerry qui sut il se
dit qu'est ce qu'il est fort il sert à
rien
ck serra et celui de l'autre côté elle
est vraiment fort maxime rien je
retourne marché un peu mais il passe sa
vie autour de la partie de maxime qui
est tous les jours en fait tu sais où tu
mates sur n'importe quelle taille il va
toujours passer devant maxime lemire
quoi ses rangs un oiseau de mauvaise
augure regard hagard regarde le psg 4e à
partir regarde regarde le fabre eux
gardent le les amis le cavalier g4 est
en approche
bien évidemment il vient de passer
devant la caméra et j'ai heureusement il
ya une caméra c'est pas pour passer
devant toutes les trois minutes
une fois posé sa veste dessus
contrepoint counsel
non mais il doit avoir une zone se sont
a pas le droit de marcher devant la
caméra
enfin gérard bout d'un moment ça va il y
passe à gauche à droite sirpa sur aurore
passé derrière ainsi tous devront lever
un pion de pénalité quoi tomber quatre
pythons qu'on avait acquis rage
si tu prends comme ça c'est mais avec la
capote cathédrale cathédrale si tu
soulèves le y est tu leur tournoi pour
faire un minuscule je vais dire un y
le cratère de 100 points
mallet
voyez français trois basses et des x men
aux femmes c'est qu'il reprend donc
viennent même pas où 4 une bonne idée
pour abandonner
oui non mais c'est ce qu'ont bien dans
les céciliennes mais avant celle-là très
particulière parce que d'habitude quand
tu fais ton rose et 3 tu veux faire
faire des français aux blancs et tu
auras abîme la structure de pions tout
ça l'a gagné 1,4 à la la c'est très bien
fait et change la tour c 8 montre le
cavalier de saut spécial un bon gars
auraient pu faire bon alors pourquoi
vous en fait sur lequel j'ai quatre lors
que les blancs ont toujours un net
avantage mais parce qu'on est français
les amis les charbons femme qu'est ce
que tu peux nous sortir son drapeau au
rap ou le drapeau jaune rappelé au
drapeau on est toujours là les amis
tayem un peu de l'autre côté à tanger
toute la france de l'autre côté ça vient
de faire les écharpes faire un produit
dérivé la même écharpe avec écrit fonce
dessus à benghazi c'est exceptionnel
sera exceptionnel je pense c'est
faisable on aurait contacté les gens qui
font ces écharpes très qualitative avec
alela front soit et ce serait
fantastique la charte allez la france
ouais au sursaut être fait avant oui
quelqu'un qui va lancer ce business et
qui n'est pas devenir milliardaire bon
d'accord elle invite au resto pour fêter
ça mais non pour qu'on s'enflamme
stratégique a tancé par l'inf la madame
c'est que ça met une part d'incertitude
apprécions évidemment qu'on lisait le
camp gkp tout seul là bas un peu dans un
no man's land il fait peur à voir
mais d'un coup se fait calculer des
trucs à kiev 2-1 peut-être des trucs
trois peut-être deux ans et je suis d'un
caillou trop échec et en pratique
maxime peut être à l'aise dans ce genre
de marne au free willy chung ça me
saoule en fait un truc normal soul folk
et du cassoulet il a évidemment c'est
n'importe quoi mais this way
si ça marche verte est très con en face
de moi en fait c'est pas si claire kg 4
donc fait objectivement marine et blanc
sont mieux mais bon il ya vraiment rien
de fait et donc vu le style des joueurs
ce qu'ils aiment bien même position quoi
c'est pour ça qu'on veut voir calenge et
4 kw à son héros de tours donc à la
france et sa capitale pour y j'ai trouvé
sept corps est alors un jeu très heureux
j'ai senti que ça allait de faire rire
le bloquiste en génial bokros encore
pourquoi nos week-ends sans y croire et
là c'est du rock sm5 abondance 5,7 m
marc marquez assez bref le casque on va
voir si great food fait 5 mes5 ce
qu'aime le coup qui part tout seul quoi
faire ce petit pion qui avance et en
fait on peut pas le bouffer parce que le
cas il n'y a plus de défenses moi c'est
la merde opi prises et donc lui qu'est
ce qu'il veut faire revenir la en mur et
se fout on peut-être l'idée de max et de
faire ça et tu te dire ah ben je fais un
truc très compliqué ici mais bajan pas
tout à l'heure on n'aime pas pousser les
pions dans son rap ça l'affaiblît la
diagonale seraient toutes ouvertes sur
un cahier des cinq la dame peut
reprendre ou quoi ça a l'air de faire
peur donc je sais pas quel est des deux
maximum avec comment comment comment il
fut enfin je sais pas j'ai l'impression
juste que c'est horrible en fait là ce
qu'il a fait le retour du calbertois
traîné sur f5
moi je pensais vraiment il allait partir
skier g4 et [ __ ] le bordel
justement parce qu'il faut juger cette
heure parce que ça vient ça c'est juste
le cas d'école de ce que tu ne veux
jamais avoir genre qu'il va faire tour f
l'athena imite m6 où les fuites sur
france 5 qui va partir le tpr et clément
et je pense qu'il va jouer quelque chose
comme ça l'artisane égal mais est ce que
le tout rachat il donne quelque chose ne
veut pas croire ça c'est une première
moi non plus ce que j'aime pas enfin moi
ce que j'aime pas du tout au delà de ce
que j'ai à dire c'est que c'est palm
s'est pas maxime ce que dit souvent baky
quand tu vas jouer comme ça c'est pas
maxime n'a lui va vers l'avant et 5 très
vite demain qui va turbines j'ai même
pas ici si tu fais d'un direct mais pour
quel g3 sur m6 je suis sur une bonne
idée quand même mais bon c'est vrai tu
peux te le garder en réserve
malgré tout que je pense qu'il va le
pousser et adam h1 évidemment fil des
tours prend h5 d'un prince 5 2e tour en
h1 ans a normalement c'est intenable
normalement je sais pas je
ouais comment ils passent à côté de ces
candidats pour le moment écoutant le
contenu si la paire comme ça mais on va
voir si jamais si jamais
enfin peu un coup de chance parce que en
fait si green shoe que joue bien son
attaque jo bacon c'est possible de
résister t'as plus ton destin entre les
mains quatre n'ont pu se caler premier
cas tout à fait du goût moi en fait tf6
pour cavaler à chaque jeu ça me choque
en quelque sorte que projet se prendre
fait sur regard la séquence par beaucoup
en fait ya jamais de monde où tu veux te
prendre fou g7
enfin en gros l'idée de fougères et 4
c'est une saison qui s'est donné deux
coups au blanc et en plus un les diodes
pour 9,6 ouais c'est tout ce que les
blancs rêve de faire en vrai c'est une
attaque modèle sur le roi tu as
l'impression que c'est vraiment les
parties de fisher des années 70 60 même
tu as tu as l'impression je n'aime pas
jouer conception et à l'impression dans
les années 60 on pensait encore avec
ténors que ça pouvait tenir dans
quelques cas de figure 1
et après on a juste compris que ben non
en fait je fais tout dans ma tête oui
bonjour
et bah écoutes je sais pas on va voir on
va voir on va on va mais bon pas vous
cacher que je déteste la position de max
on va avoir un vrai ce que moi ce que je
déteste c'est le contenu de puits a
depuis lundi un contenu pas génial
contenu pas génial
oui c'est ça qui me fait peur en fait
c'est même pas ce coup de quadrillage 5
concrètement c'est juste que ça donne
l'impression de
ouais d'un contenu faible un côté maxime
pour le moment ils n'arrivent pas à bien
jouer alors j'espère quand même qu'il
sauve la nulle c'est encore sauvable non
mais tu peux même gagné en fatigue il
faudra que la taxe devrait y croit
mattei fait un sacrifice à une défense
bombe
il ya pas mal et pas mal mais problème
c'est que c'est des trucs aussi simple
aussi naturelle une attaque comme ça que
le soir d'un bébé je sais pas qui avait
dit ça à ces fiches arnon bas c'était
sur la partie de charbon de larsson je
suis pas si c'est lui qui le dit
approuver ces temps ci c'est dans ce
livre les 60 meilleures parties de
fisher est aussi naturelle sa cravate et
des couloirs fc un gâchis je mets ton à
charge sacrifie je te bouffe je
m'attends h c'est tout bon donc voilà
c'est pas trop compliqué le plan il est
connu que deux gratte tout cas sept ans
il connaît ce à quoi m après maximy peu
je peux faire un coup de marloux qui va
défendre mais c'est vrai que dans le
fond de jeu
c'est inquiétant un maxima weick on va
on va pas repasser tout l'historique de
la début du début d'année de max may
have eyes qui l'a déjà très mal joué on
s'était rassuré en disant que cariat qui
n'a émaillé les candidats derrière
caruana avait très mal joué la veille
qu'il avait gagné les 40 candidats
derrière mais là le problème c'est qu'on
est vraiment dans la lignée du niveau de
device qui est plus autour d'un top 25
top-30 monde
c'est plus du vie dit quoi hein mais
sans manquer de respect à vie dit il ya
maxime on aura bien sûr non mais tu as
ça c'est plus au niveau de jeu d'un vidy
d'un ak murat tu vois toujours qu'ils ne
vont pas des candidats qua non mais
vraiment pu sans rigoler depuis vas y
que ça ressemble plus à ce à quoi tu
atari
presque non mais atari en grande forme
c'est dire non mais tu arrives tu
exagère mais tu as à 27,50 quoi ça joue
à 27,50 assez génial hein comme niveau
c'est du très haut niveau mais c'est
plus 27 81 28 il ya eu un pas en arrière
clairement et le truc c'est que ça se
répète sur un peu toutes les parties
qu'on voit quand même
écoutons pas abattre non mais j'espère
que enfin pour moi en fait à n'importe
quel moment maxime peut retrouver son
niveau
une fulgurance il peut avoir une fugue
ans est retrouvé le truc quoi
mais bon et là que je pense moi ça
dépend pas de lui on va de cette partie
maintenant c'est fini maintenant ça
dépend plus du nom syrie d'où vient la
grèce vous bien et yann cas mais enfin
j'ai apparaît que maxime ce qui s'est
passé de la confiance c'est bien mais
ici me suffirait d'une étincelle ça il
manque qu'une étincelle quoi il n'est
pas loin de l'avoir ce niveau il la
donne by iphone on mai jerry tu sens que
dans les partis là et à chaque fois dans
toutes les parties combat il ya un
moment où sommes là ça glisse ou comme
contre gilad est un foie ou comme contre
ding c'est à dire que là en fait il va
il va avoir de nouveau son niveau de jeu
c'est sûr mais il a cette glissade dans
toutes les parties c'est ça qui
m'inquiète c'est qu'un maximum en grande
forme il te fait des parties parfaites
un peu de l'avant
faites très bien autant vouloir tout
calculé jusqu'au match et perdre et puis
bah en fait de paraître
et voilà mais bon mais bon je trouve
toujours pas cette partie référence moi
c'est ça qui m'inquiète moi je cherche
la partie rémy julienne celle là même
sans référence se trouve tube avec thank
you parce que même sans bien bien sûr
non non c'est encore c'est encore
possible un faible c'est encore possible
on est d'accord mais je suis toujours
confiant quand elle est partie j'ai ok
ça y est il a retrouvé la forme
aujourd'hui il va bien jouer
qu'aujourd'hui on retrouve maxime à
chaud je me dis ça avant les primes on
va voir mais bon il cite balance le f5
je sais pas quand je vois pas comment
ils jouent peuvent donc
donc dur
sur cette séquence presse avec l'équipe
de france de foot a été championne du
monde sans s'en produire un jeu
exceptionnel 1 en 2018 bah oui rien fait
en fait un timing pour devant et c'est
ça oui bah on a été champions du monde
en faisant air bags van marcke ces
penaltys basse et ça va la grille tout
qu'il a la possession
bravo enfin non mais c'était et compact
en 2008 et grand chose alors à se
regarder dans le blanc des yeux un c'est
pas vivant vous attirer bien des coups
de pied arrêtés c'était clinique savais
tu avais une munition ça il a gâché pas
quoi en corner par une tête de mule qui
tire un coup-franc bam une tête de
varane c'est pareil va faire une gaffe
et puis vim
bah voilà second poteau par quoi on va
voir on va voir on peut encore gagner
son match référence
on peut gagner sans son match référence
fab justement supporters de la squadra
zoah un beau ça peut faire des 0-0 en
groupe
rien faire les choses du monde
bombardier vise à guider la marque un
but ils regardent bah oui peut le faire
nancy a retrouvé le second souffle obama
non mais bon ça me fait un conjoint
comme cavalier h5 que j'ai envie de
l'envoyer valdinguer tout et puis une
barrière qui disent qu est ce que toi tu
est à 2 ça me fait chier enfin je vois
un truc comme ça ça me fait chier enfin
très clairement je te dis la vérité
femmes
on n'est pas là pour voir des coups
comme cavalier h5 enfin juste j'ai envie
de voir les fins c'est frustrant en fait
sur s'ils étaient moins forts que les
autres
après les paquets piétons plus s'il
était vraiment moins fort que les autres
tu vois mon nom
oui non mais enfin on écoute on va voir
la bombe en fait d'être un bon scénario
en fait cela en fait vous m'avez tous
qui est plus dans sa prépa c'est clair
c'est plus possible
comment j'aurais pu imaginer que les
battants qui s'est tenue il va réfléchir
minutes il va vouloir mater bon il va
jouer pas trop mal et puis à un moment
il va jouer sur trente secondes et ça va
se retourner maximale pas de nom c'est
vrai c'est vrai je passais juste c'est
mal joué en fait les coûts sont mauvais
mais le scénario peu et trompe toi il a
tout fait bien se passer quoi il ya un
monde où ça existe tout ça sera un
compte via le i
je veux être dans ce monde en crise
pas se cacher enfin s'y perd hiller
encore une microscopique chances de
l'emporter
microbes c'est le 3 sur 3 c'est toujours
possible de faire 3 sur 3 à 1 mais
mais après tu te dis bombe qu'on peut
faire quand tu as fait un sur quatre
pour que tu as fait trop sur trois d'un
coup c'est pas la tendance sais rien je
sais plus y'a plus rien de rationnel là
je sais plus je me pose plus de
questions non mais je m'oppose pas
d'ailleurs on peut aller voir deux
secondes battant brive 5e demi heure en
plus il prend même pas tout son temps il
encore 29 minutes mais il a vraiment
envie de gagner là c'est terrible
en fait il a envie de montrer à la
russie qu'il aide n'est pas un nom mais
aussi montrer qu'il a sa place pour cela
vous présentant avec un tour du lac
simcoe quoi ça son palmarès le détail ce
que j'ai battu alex nichols j'imagine il
gagne la faillite a il est vrai comme
quoi ça se joue à rien c'est tourner à
ce jour un seul jour un sage ou tempo
bref des 8
bon nous on s'attend epci siparex dames
ainsi le coût de leur dit ce que
quelqu'un dise à tchatcher fut quand mes
erreurs
on va voir
on va réfléchir même temps donc c'est
vraiment le coup de biologie que maxime
a joué comme ça sur la tristesse pour
ton fou et tu défendes et si ce n'est
pas fait nul ouais c'est nier
bonbons sans trop de risques le nez
pauvres
donc à tort d'élite qu'est ce qui va
qu'est ce qu'il va faire f six mois je
l'enverrai mais bon toi tu dis que tu
temporisera attendant voilà deux saisons
moi je ferais which they will fall est
en reprise et moi le tarif 6 aussi
mesdames - damas et qu'il garde en chat
y avait un module qui si c'est très fort
et si si les dames mains d'un machin
pour prendre cinq dans le premier cinq
îlots tourache de plans voilà il ya
combien de temps avec 28 minutes
en fait le truc c'est que même en bulles
est toujours plombé n'ont pas besoin
d'une nouvelle vont trouver quoi
réveiller des fois tu sais quand à +10
mais du coup je veux dire je vais
finasser jeu l'un va peut-être qu'il ya
cette défense si tu te fais des fantômes
est en ruines ça ça arrive à tous
niveaux en plus c'est terrible
dix femmes le truc c'est que ça se joue
avec les mains c'est pour ça que
j'arrive pas à comprendre comment max et
rentrer là dedans ils ont fait il a un
très bon bah oui c'est mieux que nous
déjà mais il a un très bon feeling pour
ces trucs qui se joue qui s'attaquent y
voir que les gens pratiquent le
dynamisme quoi tout simplement
et donc mes donc j'ai tout petits avec
les gibbons voit ça se trouve je vais
faire un petit dames 1
enfin petite dame 1 ici parce que
pourquoi pas en fait il a besoin de
ramener ces pièces lourdes sur la
colonnade donc la dame qui viennent là
est peut-être qu'elle rebondisse ici un
jour 55 amg 3l peux m'en lave à sagelat
excusé kg 3 te reprendre ça c'est cool
et dames nendaz machin tout reprend
pions prend ou cette dame qui était ici
elles prendraient et elle aurait libéré
cette case pour l'autre tour et donc si
vous imaginez bien une dame
il a toujours ses cases rouges qui
menacerait option c'est un peu ça l'idée
et on nous demandait si ce sacrifice n
est si souveraine de cavalli france et
qui rappelle d'un match 6 et le problème
dans tous ses ventes d'options qui est
haussé ses pions donc ça ça va pas faire
une caisse de moi enfin en plus au-delà
de la taxe et la jouer dans l'autre sens
alors peut-être ça tient un peu mieux
mais on n'est pas longtemps raillé une
pièce de moins quoi travailler à
l'avenir les cavaliers vont arriver
enfin fait
si vous donnez une pièce faut au moins
qu'ils aient des compensations et là en
fait vous avez une pièce de moins et
l'attaqué contre vous en fait ça va pas
trop quoi france ce soir on va t'aider
croustibat un coup steve ott
il me reste un peu mou ça va les partis
comme ça sur jeu d'ailleurs directeur
bien sûr voilà ça ne gagne pas plus à 6
à spa ce scénario-là cecos qui bat qu'on
galère terminé on n'en parle plus peut
être plus
je regarde que tu te dis à positionner
là ça me bon match
la chance allait juste sait-on ps c'est
ta chance et grichka à cette opposition
à rendre qu'à roanne abouba temps mais
elle est moins pire
cette position là que ding ding ding lei
ah ouais non elle est moins pire qu'on
ding tour f3c banding c'était vraiment
c'est plus que perdu enfin c'était je
pense que tout restera il abandonné
quasiment poitiers tard il s'éteint il a
été un coup très facile de l'abandon
maintenant on est mieux contre eux ding
très bien j'ai déjà coin phil golding
s'avouait de même favori pour gagner
alors voir adding c'était vraiment quasi
un penalty sans gardien web os x mais
oui enfin c'est juste incroyable et -13
3 tours 38 rondes porte ou des bons
vieux tubes au même syndrôme gagné une
partie ouest fait longtemps qu'il a pas
gagné gris cheveux qu'il a peu joué
qu'il aurait fait aller 1
ça passe par là demain
des échecs un moment est grave elle
s'écroule pas et pas tout à fait vrai
c'est la première fois que maxime vous
les candidats et en plus maxime s'était
même pas qualifiés 1 ils jouent les
candidats parlent de par le retrait d'un
job d'un autre joueur donc si vous aviez
suivi toute la phase de qualification
des candidats maxime a raté quoi 3 4
fois la qualif
ouais 37 cette fois là et sur lucic
d'avant tet2 donc il a raté peut-être
cinq fois la qualif est donc là en
réalité on n'a jamais eu un aussi haut
niveau après des succès vous la seconde
s'est passé quoi jusqu'à y est moins
fort là pour le moins sur ce tournoi la
face en cette phase retour la phase
aller ils avaient été très très forte
il abat deux victoires 5 nuls très très
bien quoi et la sas moins bien mais bon
en fait autant faut pas vendre la peau
d'ours en vertu et chanté avant que
avant d'être qualifiés ou quoi autant
dans le sens inverse
tu peux pas enterrer des gens tant que
mathématiquement ce profit est la peur
car aujourd'hui c'est pas fini la partie
serait perdue battue peut encore revenir
donc c'est pas le moment de 2,2 je sais
pas remise en question
il a un fils a jamais été un aussi haut
niveau de la compétition maxime non elle
a parfois qu'il est chiot donc on peut
pas dire maxime s'écroule enfin après il
a fait des coupes du monde dès détruit
mais pourtant mais ces candidats c'est
le truc c'est le truc ultime et
il est 2e ex-aequo donc
oui face oui c'est pas nous c'est
dommage que ça arrive à ce moment là
beaucoup mieux quand il était 20e
mondiale et qui ne s'était pas qualifié
non il est très très bien maxime l'a
tout de même on
même si fini quatrièmes des candidats
c'est quand équivalente 5e mondial qua
non avait une envie pas mais c'est quand
même très très bien mais après il est
pas son pic de forme maxime très
clairement dans le jeu il n'est pas il
est pas à son meilleur niveau mais ça
arrive ça devient très bon c'est mieux
quand ça va bien donc on va voir et puis
là il est loin d'avoir perdu en fait la
maj et la partie ou great choc peut
déconner ouais épinac simili pas mal
pour toi des ressources
il va trouver des couches y va entre les
meilleurs coups à déconcentrer il est là
il va tout donner quoi on va voir
évidemment on préférait la position sens
inverse contre sens contre sens mais bon
on m'a emmené dans le sens unique on y
va à quoi est si fine il a plus de
chances de gagner les candidats à brassy
ici fait nulle part est bien en fait
ouais d'une ça va ça va ré c'est le
scénario même que je prévoyais nul ils
gardent 20% de chances de gagner quand
ces deux défaites il passe à 1 % 1
défaite c'est qu'ils vont finir pas à
temps c'est pas finir si peu bad à 16 go
en ligne contrôlé poki tremblay c'est
possible un nom mais nul aujourd'hui
tout va bien nul aujourd'hui tout va
bien des fêtes si jamais tu vois très
bien d'ailleurs s'ils gagnent ouais il
est très vite favoriserait et si finul
20%
tu venu chez nul ça va c'est correct
céder ce qui était prévu dans mais quand
j'imagine alias de la partie la ronde
afin que les pauvres anyway moi ça c'est
fait et que donc maxime aussi et qui
restent à portée de fusil parce que bon
par contre faudra gagner demain ça ça
voilà mais vraiment à l'excès une qu il
a l'air d'être prenable oui oui oui il
est prenable mais alive pas très bien
dans ce tournoi pour mieux jouer son
niveau mais il va peut-être gagner un
compte spécial il ya une belle position
j'ai fait un petit tour pour voir donc
on verra qui est en tout cas ce
commencent à se mettre mal autant il est
en approche du design hot c'est plutôt
une bonne nouvelle
il veut comme tu le disais calculé
jusqu'au bout et ça ça peut être une
photo un joueur russe
non mais je suis souvent même quand même
qui retombe dans ses travers réfléchis
tout de même à l'otan tu sais que tu es
mieux tu comment pas qu'il y ait un gain
en force et cette xbox je vous êtes
mieux et c'est tout et et après avec la
pression du temps un tout petit peu et
qu'on s'est assuré donc
donc voilà ça c'est notre espoir dans la
partie calcul sacha ça peut être
enfin comme toujours aux échecs ça
paraît simple l'extérieur quand tu es
dans la partie 1 mais 2 des ventes la
merde mais ça sort rien n'échappe à toi
il peut y avoir le bas justement le cas
tueur dont je parlais tout à l'heure
bon je vais montrer un fût pas je vois
je vous des coûts avec avec les noirs à
toute proche 5
il ya ce cas de figure la marche que
dans tous les sens alors après là il y
aurait dû prioriser dame prend mais bon
achat mais non mais des idées comme ça
mais il ya des jt comme ça ouais mais
malheureusement je vois pas ce que je
vous disais je vois pas vraiment de nos
moyens de défendre avec les noirs si si
les blancs ça joue bien elle attaque
mais on peut garder qu'on semble bon et
qui ne marche pas et ça c'est la chance
à saisir si elle se présente parce que
entre f6 maintenant au tour des agendas
main kg 3 je sais pas il ya plein de
goût donc donc donc avoir le temps défie
le temps file côté sacha chaque seconde
qui passe me rassure c'est de plus en
plus rassurés
je suis très rassuré très bientôt parce
que les seconds ont continué de tourner
quoi on peut juste deux mandats les
avoir guéris
ce que ça donne alors pendu et ou alors
c'est un peu bougé elle a fait h4 mais
la viande plus en fait ouais c'est chaud
ok on verra compliqué compliqué mais
guérit prend sa chance il tente donc la
gare il envoie à presse et c'est ce
qu'on pensait avant le début du tournoi
un geek à roanne on avait dit c'est ce
qu'ils sont le des plus intenses sur des
périodes je vous admire main sur la
forme du moment très fort bien préparé
de façon qu'ils auront avancé préparer
forme je trouve pas que sont très en
forme car honneur mais bon juste il peut
quand même malgré tout sur le niveau de
fonds intrinsèque être là mais disons
sur le début de l'année 2001 qui
risquent peut-être qu'il vaut mieux
comme ça pourrait être un match à deux
entre guy et népotiste histoire
mais ça dépend je pense que nous fait
maxime ici son tour à ce jour là en tout
cas dans la profondeur la maxime d'où ça
vient
il peut quasiment perdre les candidats
ici vous soumettre bien vous rester en
course voire même c'est ça en cas de nul
c'est bien c'est logique que vous n'y a
rien à dire sur m6 fait fuite ouais je
pense romain mieux que fois je suis
témoin enterré quoi vous les filles tu
peux espérer faire des cinq portières
par là bas un terrain de ces quatre
cantons ensuite enfuis toi
siaci qu'est ce qui se passe ils étaient
entre deux joueurs à la fin on regarde
leur rencontre directe donc mentionné
qu'il a battu deux fois bas c'est le
gars qui a gagné deux fois même s'il a
gagné une fois et fait nul c'est pour ça
qu'on aimerait juste un ou maxi le
rattrape n'est pas comme maxime a battu
n'est pas au match aller bassil le
rattrape ce à dire qu'il perdrait pas là
donc ils mèneraient à minima un ennemi
0,58 et du coup ils passeraient devant
c'est ça aussi le motif d'espoir ici
jamais les deux joueurs sont à égalité
qu'ils ont fait pour me de nul ou une
victoire et une défaite
là ils te prennent le sun bamberger donc
c'est une manière de les partager ton
d'affirmer comme ça c'est en fait tu
sais bien la voiture des mecs qui ont
bien finir le tour passe tu prends leur
point rome s'est abattue quelqu'un qui a
fait sept points tout à sept points des
partages c'est a fait nul tu prends la
mode et de ses points 3,2 me et a perdu
a battu les prend pas j'aime pas du tout
ceci therese partagèrent complètement
rapid rien comme c'en est un mais je
veux dire savoir qu'ils allaient partage
parfait mais c'est vrai que ce serait
mieux que juste les deux soirées à fond
dans l'encré dans ce rapide de menacer
la vie moi j'aime bien ces gens cumulent
les points que tu avais après chaque
ronde a le plus hâtif le curatif ou bien
partir tu es content ouais mais j'aime
bien que ça donne un avantage celui qui
partent bien passé qui part mal en fait
il peut avoir un peu de rng convoyer des
ruines pour te rattraper t'avais qu'à
bien partir surtout dans l'est dans les
open
ouais quand enrico d'efforts même dans
les fermes et en fait pris primeur à
celui qui était leader quelque part
vous avez amené le tournoi et c'est lui
qui doit près serré pour tenir et c'est
plus dur quoi j'ai jamais vu le
cumulatif dans l'escaut des ratures et
c'est comme l'attaqué ricard ouanna
mvele en fait ils envoient tous des all
in et ça passe ça passe pas ou quoi et
le mec en fait qui vous sérieux tout le
tournoi
ben il n'est pas avantagé par rapport à
ça je trouve qu'il devrait y avoir un
avantage à bas bien commencer quoi
forcément je vais même truc dans le chat
qui parle et lisa f 6 - bien que x 3
d'après leur dit en fait foi trop ce
qu'on ait pas de retard pour qu'ils en
parlaient en fait c'est juste une
bouffée baker calvet week-end des 5 et
j'ai compris et j'aurais pas le coût ne
serait pas hyper logique mais bon c'est
hyper logique parce que en plus avec
motion se positionnait non plus après
chaque fois trop saturé trois faucons bk
dans les dessins créés mais j'aurais pas
vu en partie seulement que j'aurais même
pas regardé non j'aurais pas ce côté de
l'échiquier way qui joue le mauvais fou
conclut bamba maso il aurait pu trouver
ça tu vas par exemple je te poche
quelques touches mais un client déçu
mais déjà proche de voir ouais il faut à
3 francs bk je pensais juste c'est juste
qu'un strada f6 on a dit peter seul coup
qui passait le coût humain en fait mais
qui est pas le meilleur donc peut-être
comme un être humain peut se planter ici
un ordi sûr qu'il ya une manne être
humain peut se planter
mais il faut à trois ça marche plus
pourquoi des cinq à des cinq pas ce que
vous promet 4 tu te cloud apps ok j'ai
compris c'est pour les gens c'est
terrible hein c'est fou à face tu fais
parfois trop le coup d'avancé sur
montauban maintenant oui bien sûr mais
je leur parle assez fois à trois c'est
tellement parfait simple et complexe à
la fois contre ce qui est des cinq ici
c'est possible pour bien pas se prendre
des cinq productions et
dit bon voilà tu bouges plus rien j'ai
de faire du tour h inverse du cahier g3
de fermer machin est alors que leurs dix
dames f2 égal je vais me faire ces
quatre jeux blancs de me tirer dessus a
forcé quatre marlou d1 mais pas
maintenant si les moyens le marlou des
andes mais
oui du coup mais c'est repenser avec
beaucoup de choix donner un exemple de
comment maxime peut égaliser en fin
d'après- l'ordi visuellement c'est
toujours bien pour les noirs mais en
fait si le redis je pense que c'est bien
c'est que ça va tenir si je tour des
achats du coup je vais me faire planter
en fait tu veux te faire le kg 3
aujourd'hui il va te refaire ce truc un
fait qui s'est trop car enfin c'est
juste pour montrer un du coup il va
trouver ce truc là il va même là mais
bon tu peux revenir tu veux tu es blanc
tu blagues ou quoi bein mais ses rivaux
il peut se tromper fabre non mais c'est
ce que je dis depuis deux heures c'est
mon motif d'espoir mais dame nature le
même plan qualifiant et kg 3 battu
l'échangé de cavaliers mais c'est vrai
que l'idée de faire 4 h 5 un moment qui
avait livré 3 ok bon mot kelly prend ça
va partir je pourrais déjà alors dit il
est beaucoup moins affolé 1 et 10 k et
pranger trois prises des tours c5 dont
ces cinq matches cinq france ouais le h5
prise en passant rage sept bons et pas
très beau mais c'est pas perdu on sait
pas ce match et il n'y a pas la taille
de matelas si on me semble juste
évidemment un fruit pourri et c est ça
ça donne quoi
mais ce qu'on peut pas revenir sacrifier
ça c'est dommage d'autant plus inquiet
matin à mais du coup est ce qu'on ne
fait pas juste ce match est en tous les
cas
ouais 6 7 5
je ne crois pas je pars là bas ben je
jeu perdant près leur dit des quatre
caisses à tour dire j'adore ça permet de
compresser extraordinaire damesin rsa
c'est typique quand j'aurai truc que tu
peux te prendre un bain ça peut ça peut
en vrai mais un truc défendre et ça peut
ça c'est complètement fou c'est quoi ces
prix ça h5 va-tout rage 3 je crois c'est
tellement logique des cinq mois je vous
le jeu on le voit que ses pulls brodés
5e
ouais enfin le même thème là-bas je
en fait ça fera pas faire vraiment en
ligne
mais en fait tu comprends pas comment il
est comme je me répète mais c'est juste
cette pollution tue jamais rentré dedans
normes at you tube tu fais tout pour pas
rentrer dedans tu veux pas mais
écoutons à voir ici a une chance de
faire une vente à la con qu'on a vu
qu'un tour d'un don de ces où il verra
pas ce qu'il va être que là pour ça à
l'affût il a fait plein d'études il y
fait c'est toujours calculer quoi cavale
et f4 en plus j'ai peur que tf1 juste
pour illustrer sa gagne direct l'échec
est damée cash 5 tu prends tout où tu
vas au monde quelques variantes pour
apprendre et voir cimetière de l'attak
et pourquoi en fait on quand il a fait
cavalier f6 en vrai pourquoi on était
sûr qu'il ferait carré lâche car les g4
que ça ça se voit vraiment que 1 soit
1000 kilomètres sans calculer un peu
trop souffrir d'un bébé qu'on met du
coup dans ce quart est fait plutôt qu'il
prend un caprice prise free s appuie
aussi ça mais en fait ce qui t'as pu et
c'est mieux que ça pue comme ça que
j'étais un gosse c'est pas ça va perdre
aussi mais c'est pour ça qu'on fait
c'est une énorme prépare un great food
andré aussi tâche de la position est
vraiment dur à jouer probablement ce que
get you came rentrer là dedans de
manière tu es assez sûr de lui là sa
nouveauté il ya le messenger 9 laddh qui
fait penser qu'il était hyper près
c'est juste une mauvaise partie de
maxime jusqu'à la phase iib perdre comme
ça j'ai l'impression qu'on revit
vraiment les parties et que je regardais
fois que je suis en intérim
non mais tu as ces candidats 59e bah
c'est juste un mec très fort avec un peu
moins fort il se fait ce match on sait
pas trop pourquoi
non mais ça me fait penser aux
afficheurs avec les blancs contre les
dragons où il invite à vous d'inventer
des phares à l'époque ça n'existait pas
alors oui mais j'ai le four b3 j'ai eu
le temps de faire à trois je sais pas
quoi contrat mais qui avait fait 1
s'éprend b pour mettre son roi à l'abri
ou ce genre de choses
lila propose des solutions
en fait ouais je vais bien je vais grand
lille à ce qui veut dire pourquoi je
bois pas en quoi ça changerait la
révolution à l'avant à la position mais
en fait ce genre de trucs essayez de
s'activer espérer un miracle façon sarr
transposant cette position en fait rien
de voir mon équipe a battu peu plaisir
aux contours h3 je ne sais pas trop
comment comptes-tu genre dire mieux
ouais ouais turdu lâche 5 mois sacrifice
eu certainement sur 1,3 me vante en fait
on met toutes les tours / h la dame
et puis on sacrifie on prend et on
arrive donc c'est chaud chaud c'est très
chaud ok
la magie c'est terrible fab
c'est le moment de remettre une petite
pub avant le zeit note qui pourrait être
décisif inde en cédant ses candidats ça
je la mets un peu en avance voilà comme
ça on souffle un difficile en cette
journée femmes à vivre ensemble
bah ouais surtout que bas noté plutôt
jeu trop content quoi de l'ouverture sur
une ouverture de bons mots à jouer c'est
compliqué position qui si elle est bien
maxime il est à l'aise et bon voilà ça
se passe mal ouais bah il faut finir la
question
beaucoup de temps quarante minutes
alors après ce que tu joues fille c'est
souvent ce qui fait en fait je vous
invite finalement pour espérer planter
un truc mais voilà si chaude je vais
vite s'est pas tu joue vite avec
l'initiative et je vis de tema tempête
ouais c'est même dur de faire ça avec
ange henri iv compte ding ouais tu peux
jouer vite montre son vrai nom n'a là en
vrai c'est compliqué c'est un moment
difficile là après même si père y aura
encore un mini espoir normalement ils
purent en espoirs mais ce serait pas
mathématiquement fini c'est juste en cas
de nul que ça va correctement c'est pas
de la fausse annonce de bois quoi dire
s'ils annulent ça va sinon ça va très
bien nul défaite ça va pas trop mal est
fait ça oblige 3 sur 3 ou alors
peut-être un cas ou deux et demi en
battant dépôt sur la route ça va ouais
mais bon c'est pas le truc le plus
probable c'est évidemment à huy
et caraïbes 4 on l'a montré un c'est
juste dommage de en fait je prends ça
devrait pas en fait le problème vous
préviens si les noirs exemple une
colonne h
on va dire un mur sur l'échiquier avec
ses pions en quinconce ne s'est pas
confirmée fcl g6 et f6 g5 en face et
l'europe peut pas s'en aller et donc les
blancs vont entrer en force parce que
ils ont une pièce qui coulisse ils ont
l'espace ça allie des avantages des
espaces verts que les blancs ils ont des
cases ici pour pièces lourdes dam tour
comme ils veulent
il peut venir de loin bon ben là vers ce
n'est pas vrai quoi ça ça veut pas venir
se joindre aux jeux par ici donc c'est
ça toute la difficulté
donc les blancs ils veulent que lui
disparaissent et te dire moi j'arrive
tu peux vraiment pas défendre tête
j'aimerais bien avoir un roi g7 torah je
suis très bas taux horaire est donc tu
adores ray depuis tout à l'heure c'est
pour ça qu'on regarde les variantes à
base de h5 ainsi de solidifier tous à
dire bon bassin gelé qui se défendre
c'est bon et si tu me prends je mets le
voilà bon déjà c'est pas la panacée mais
athée plus mat ce que lui c'est un
bouclier tartas vous mettre une tour une
tour une dame nombre à super c'est un
pas plus loin que ça mais mais en fait
il ya encore pire même ça déjà c'est
chiant les éclés blanc ils se disent bon
vas-y je reviens et puis je reviens et
puis je te prends et puis j'aimais de la
dame et je prends avec la dame donc on a
déjà montré pas mal d'exemples mais si
jamais je suis jouer n'importe comment
je ne résiste pas je fais l'agneau
menace maths on prend 1 prend c'est
imparable la dame la houle à n'importe
c'est ça le souci dans le fond en fait
et donc qu'avaient les f4 on va ça
marche pareil pim la dame elle débarque
ans on ramène le cavalier sont faits
droite façon ça va pas changer grand
chose parce que toute façon est ce que
ce match est la dame débarque échec et
la tour arrive en fait c'est toujours le
même scénario qui se répète
inlassablement
donc quitte à choisir faut choisir le
scénario où les blancs doivent safin
tour et trouver un truc pour survivre en
nombre d'abonnés avec la rue elle est à
la fois la folle à la au temps en temps
au temps avant un tour de plus pendant
un moment mais pas le forcer à prendre
un risque en fait c'est pas mais vous as
tu fait kf4 ton prince stress se voit
comme jamais et c'est même pas un coup
donc ne pas prendre basse et sert à rien
sans les blancs vont te bouffer en h 5
puis on prend pour prendre mon bâton
tournage cette fiesta en vie mais c'est
pas le problème n'est même pas entré
donc je pense que prendre les devants
catastrophique tant que guergis a dit
oui mais là c'est perrin cavalli et
après tu te sentais très mal à tâtons
foot cases noires horrible l'igas
partout tu as encore l'attaquent
enfin c'est un moment de silence visage
abandonnée non cic y c'est que si
pertinemment que si gris tout que joue
bien il a perdu ça il le sait mais tu
penses tu penses à tenter un dernier
piège
ben là je dis vraiment dernier c'est
vraiment dernier en fait tu
c'est que quelqu un jeu correct tomates
en quelques coups parle à tous et qui
joue contre un ordi dandy coûte
abandonné maximum oui oui ça je suis
d'accord
complètement d'accord tu veux faire
savoir en fait mais c'est quand même
embêtant parce que tu vois on a
l'impression quand même que la prépa et
va plus ou moins jusqu ici ou en tout
cas accès plus ou moins à l'écologie qui
est vraiment cette fois prête de finir
mais nous avons 605,5 propres mais c'est
peut-être comme une énorme près par rich
aucun nom déjà ces nouveautés au 9e coup
keyes clair que dans son truc et le plan
je les aime bien ce qu'il a fait sans
fait d'habitude on fait j'ai trois en
fait il a juste dit ok je m'en fiche je
te fais ça très vite et je vais te faire
mal placé et et pièces tonka et on fout
pour en profiter et donc le concept est
sympa ça t'es sympa
après les interrogations sur qu'est ce
que ça vaut concrètement on se tait les
autres ventes avant va jarlot km et 4
qui s'est si souvent des trucs de ouf
comme ça qu'est ce que ça fasse on se
laisse prendre
il comprendrait futilement je pensais
bien ici les désordres d'ânesse de alors
après ça faisait peur de toute façon
parce que la tour contournait on sait
déjà c'est machin mais bon là là là là
ça va être cool allait pas bonne on se
fait reculer chaque fois on rebouche des
mêmes pièces
ça va mal et non mais clairement
clairement c'est la série cookies c'est
la conception qui va pas en fait saisie
a du mal à arta m à mettre un coup en
rouge qua non mais juste tu peux tu dois
tout faire pour pas que ça sur
l'échiquier ça arrive donc quelque part
tu serais ce match et par une part un
problème tactique plutôt quoi c'est plus
compréhensible fait l'ajuster rentrer
volontairement dans quelque chose vous
faites ça se voit que ces abandons par
abandon façon de parler mais où ça se
voit que tu es foutu quoi je me sens de
formateurs
donc vos loft 1 situation
on va voir un sacrifié le fouet cette
balle fram ses quatorze pièces de moins
qu'en fait tu mens de tête qui
mangeaient pas fait une vidéo si si on
avait fait partie de la master class qui
sont sur la chaîne youtube
j'en avais fait une soirée pédago enfin
je suis plus constant hors classe quoi
il ya quelques mois de ça avec basso
plante pousse ses pions achoui qui
compte 900 kg et tous ses classiques -
annonce avait rien de dans l'église a
gâché quand ce n'est pas original du
tout à ce que fait gris tchouk s'est
fait huer la même enfin la même envie
donc à la prépa ou quoi mais les coûts
là ils viennent tout seuls
non mais en fait le truc ce qu'il ya
d'intéressant c'est ce qu'a fait gris
tout cas c'est pas enfin le plan soit
mon tour le connais quoi enfin georges
quand j'avais 10 ans je savais déjà
mais mais c'est de pouvoir faire marcher
en pratique ce en fait il suffit pas de
le faire les yeux fermés à chaque fois
parce qu'il ya quand même des manières
de défendre et plus qu'une
donc ça vienne pas tout seul s'est il a
trouvé un moyen de poser un problème
très concret pratique avec cette vente
là et aussi ce que vous avez dit bon
genre d'attaqués c'était souvent
corrélée avec le foot roi dame des deux
ont fait faux archi son échange de foot
cases noires l'envoi quand même une
différence parce qu'on le foot 15 nuits
line tu as envie et les blancs foulée de
ce côté donc il pas là les attaques là
bas donc ça change quand même deux trois
trucs qui il a à faire un truc assez
intéressant quand même on maxime
toujours concentré qui donne tout après
bien que vous un truc ça va pas marcher
je pense mais intéressant il dit oui on
puce 15,5 me sacrifie dessus pourquoi je
serai pas que h67 orages trois temps
malheureusement ils vont te faire la
même chose les blancs a amené ils vont
te sacrifier h six ouvrages 5 et 35 sa
tête passe tu as quand même ouvert la
colonne tous les pauvres ir et ramène la
dame ou la tour peu importe
et ils te font ça et c'est la merde
voilà donc
donc oui même âge qui serait pas mal
avec maxime vaccinés par entré dans son
tournoi ray dans le chat n'a jamais a
jamais donné l'impression de s'être
notre plénitude de ses moyens
mais bon ok il faut le miracle en fait
d'ailleurs réfléchir en tout cas ils
donnent tout oa bon ben arfa tout ce que
je raconte est ce que qu'ils racontent
bas il le sait rien il le voit et le
calcul et ça va pas ça va pas ça paraît
bon dit c'est tout simple ouais il le
sait il a toujours su saïsset depuis
qu'il est petit ce genre de position
c'est chiant mais du coup elle c'est là
mon interrogation comme toi c'est
qu'est-ce qu'il a ratée pour
entraînements c'est ça justement commune
à 44 minutes t'as pas de temps réussi en
début de partie donc tu es entrer là
dedans il a cru voir un hacker qui s'est
passé ne se rendent pas là dedans c'est
parce qu'il a raté en fait sachant qu'en
plus l'idée de l'ordi deux fois trop
franc b4 c'est peut-être encore plus
fort c'est à dire qu'il n'a pas nommé de
façon à ses fins la position lavoie
doyon c'est sûr qu'il ya plusieurs
manières
non tu rentres jamais la dent dure à
dire je sais pas je suis curieux de
cette façon pour gagner un tournoi comme
celui-là il faut il faut mieux jouer que
ça c'est sûr donc ça passe par le niveau
de jeu avant tout après la réussite à
lien où elle vient pas mais est-ce que
c'est pas dur
fede live sur twitter s'est fait perdre
son maillot et je pense je pense ça
qu'il a fait partie d'ailleurs car le
scène bientôt à granby news fini aussi
un nom n'est pas aussi du coup puisque
l'huile à feu d'épaulé à sa chaîne il a
échoué du fait des longs là il fut
rappelle qu'on s'est joués le magnus
tour il porte en laye faire des bises
juste après est ce que les peaux
n'apparaît pas perdu son niveau non mais
c'est comme ça c'est comme ça a
peut-être non mais des fois tu repars
commun où je fais tout bien et puis je
veux dire à dessein qui tente le coup de
lila downs brett hawke est bien bien
tenté ce pas censée changer le truc mais
c'est probablement la meilleure chance
pratique se lève c'est ce qu'il a il a
mis là - il a l'air de rester confiant
quand même ça c'est plutôt bien mais il
est pas comme lorsqu'il a joué quand
j'étais jeune poulain contre ding envoyé
qu'il allait abandonner là je sais pas
il est encore une puce ans qui se bat
vraiment voir j'ai tout qu'il a pris
tempo haïssez levée dès que tous qu'ils
devaient s'attendre à ça c'était pas une
surprise l'un des cinq d'un coup
ouais ben hilli devez calculer de vous
il a dû comprendre sa meilleure chance
pratique et ça devait être sa ligne 1 et
donc ils enchaînent
la suite ce que ce qui tente un raid
pour penser 3 qu'il prend des saints et
se refaire un tour en f4 soutenir
l'autre sait même pas si c'est possible
tu as des clubs surtout autour des 8
enfin west être la meilleure chance
arrêts non mais moi je sais pas je sais
pas combien de noms mais on ne peut pas
c'est dur de donner enfin tout père en
retz donc ces genres de choses que tu
sens plus son parti quand tu calcules il
pourrait y avoir une
un piège ou un truc
on va voir ce cas ça fait mal je fais
des 5 3e des directs jouent tempo ça et
tu réfléchis c'est terrible en fait oui
tu fais des cinq déjà pour espérer qu'il
ait pas trop prévu le truc
ouaip fait un peu mal autant car lequel
prend h5 pas ce que tu dis quand même
que france 5
en fait mauvaise nouvelle avec toujours
tempo prendre mon pied le meilleur coup
ils gardent le contrôle et huillard le
calibrage 5 à venir donc c'est à ce
terrible hein je vois pas vraiment
comment il va s'en sortir mais on espère
le miracle ouais ça fait fouillis zumba
café cousu mag a fait faux feuillet
carnaval quoi 4,4 teintées et tout parce
que bon on va voir enfin là on peut être
que spectateur on n'a pas de quoi
proposer ya aucun coup non effectivement
on a tout montré que le coach ancien le
coup de chance mais
au parti ça allait durer ça allait
vraiment à sens unique rappelle celle de
ding il y aura souffert avec les normes
accident ce tournoi constants je reste
plus qu'un noir mais sur les trois
partis qui les clés noires dur
finalement c'était 3 cauchemar 1 alors
est ce que finalement son erreur c'est
pas d'avoir un répertoire trop étroits
depuis beaucoup trop longtemps et ne
jamais avoir eu de plan b
je veux ce que disait maxime lagarde
un petit peu sur cinq était visée mais
bon tu envoies devises et humer le kg an
le 5 août qui est bien ou 5 c'est pas
pareil oui bien sûr c'est là qu'une
folle n'est pas réputé pour autant la
jeunesse n'est pas réputé pour autant
tutorat 7 rebonds mais les autres sont
quand même en live mettre sous pression
vite mais ils sont préparés depuis un an
sur les nages darphin mais le g20 des
bonnes ouvertures et bonne nouvelle
c'est une bonne ouverture 1 agence une
bonne ouverture mais évidemment ça peut
faire du bien de savoir voir fait mettre
le doute que le mec perdre du temps ces
prépas qui invite d'autres fichiers qui
sont brouillées la tête c'est ça ouais
c'est en plus dans ce sens là ce que la
grille tout cas l'impression qui s'est
rappelé jusqu'à jusque là il avait l'air
de vraiment avoir révisé et si tu as
vraiment révisé ça a été vraiment sûr
que c'est la position que tu vas voir
sur l'échiquier tu peux aller très loin
après tu me diras kirill avait bien une
école le matin tu sais aussi qu'il va la
jouer takhar et fils et ça aussi c'est 5
de dommages
non mais c'est dur ni les fichiers ils
font pas trop ligne d'essai des pavés
quoi c'est un petit roman à lire chaque
jour
à retenir pas que le yard a indiqué
l'institut tout écrit moi aller non mais
c'est très très difficile à
si ce nom ce pas pas fameux
d'investissement et puis on prend dame
vous reprenez la dame mais après vous
perdez une tour dans le manoeuvre même
des cats et bien je parce que ça change
fondamentalement est peut-être bon repas
de lamborghini option mais les bons
damageux ça doit être chiant
on va se passer on veut aller on attaque
la dame avec la tour derrière
enfin petit tour allez petit tour avec
stmicro en gohelle spéciale qui est
possible bizarre je m'attendais
tellement ce cahier un f5 et j'aime
aller du coup bons souvenirs de fougères
on va dire et gearing est bien y eric et
bien ça va être un petit des quatre
dames prince ici à partir à un moment un
gars qui peut gagner mais bravo lieu
parce que bon gagner sur commande combes
ding personne fait valeur c est donc lui
doit vraiment gagné parce qu'il a plus
que deux blancs dans le tournoi c'est
celle là et je sais plus on trie plus
tard et il va varier marc ayrault nantes
ça c'est pas évident et donc
aujourd'hui de regagner sa seule chance
il en train de le faire donc bravo guiry
chapeau vous faites fin alors ça fait
plusieurs jours qu'on dit qu'il est bon
et tout mais elle a vraiment belles
belles progresser dans l'attitude parce
que c'est le whip heureux machin rigoler
avec 14 parties 14 nuls à nana bon bah
là il va aller chercher les parties oui
il jouera il jouera il jouera le la
gagne qui gagne aujourd'hui avec avec
nemo et caruana népoty vois ça revient
fort en bas il va peut-être devoir
changer on faisait des pollueurs bien la
gagner contre maxime donc il aura les
blancs ou où je sais pas desmond arfa
lui doivent faire les gars du lycée qui
revient c'est grave c'est pas grave
les projets trois étrangers 3 on juge
une tour prend pas trop le choix
j'imagine est allé un piège un quelque
part
thibault de bananes traîne il en faut
une pour rester en vie
ah bon rester en vie encore en vie mais
pourra pour rester bien en vie sinon il
sera aisé comme dans les filles quand tu
te noies akwaya dernier voir et un
sourire se cabrer icool quoi sera dans
le soubresaut f5
alors qu est ce qui prend en bas sans
lui ce qui va pour le sacrifice qu'est
c'est bien maxime qui fait prendre une
décision moins elle va chercher tout
j'imagine que c'est plutôt pas prendre
mais bon
dans prime système le 4 verset du coup
patron
4 ce soir logica dimon marqué ses trois
waie tué
je suis contre et j'aime c'est peut-être
bien jeu au final sur h5 nom se veut
bien jouer c'est bien dans 209 24e coup
il reste seize coups à jouer pour
arriver à qui ça or ajoute temps 50
minutes et maxime là qui tente un bon
coup pratique assez bien joué c'est bien
je suis bon dans le bon tempo il le joue
et là il rejoue bien dormir dos au mur
il rejoue bien aller il peut la sauver
j'y crois encore fab a bien sûr ce qu'on
veut lutter c'est pas fini fins et tu
joues un ordi tu peur bon si je touche
une partie d'ordi bravo lit de mort on
attend ça fait combien de temps gris
chute a pu gagner une partie d'échecs
je n'ai pas joué aussi
non il n'a pas joué il n'avait pas gagné
dans la phase aller des candidats c'est
plus d'un an
ça vient faire un an et demi qu'il a pu
gagner great chioukh ok c'est qu'il a
fait dans le bon tempo parce que j'aille
d'emprunt fils j'avais pas pensé
je n'avais pas cette idée est lui avait
échappé aussi
ça le le fait depuis avoir gagné depuis
très longtemps ça peut faire douter ça
je ne sais plus faire
non mais c'est ça existe un le doute
parce que là en fait tripper invité
surprise en passant pas ce que tu veux
ouvrir leurs adverses
ouais mais en raison d'une trois pions
passer ta tronche un avertissement de la
partie plus tard sûrement après tu as
envie de faire ça si tu dis bon il ya
quelques années d'arrêt bon voila tu
vois bien 2005 ça va peut-être tu peux
te dire que je fais mes tours je
sacrifiés est ce que je ramène ma tour
g3 qui sert plus à rien pour mettre les
tours collet effet retour et fait un
tour à tour g1 et du coup peut-être pas
malienne des temps j'ai manqué mais le 4
mai avoir calculé tout ça parce que
bonjour tu ne marques pas tu perds
dessin et que j'en sais rien et est donc
voila et peut-être tu te dis ouais mais
en fait c'est pas mal mon g5 et si je
bloque bien j'ai une belle occasion luca
dana tu as mangé plus en contrôle
l'étude laisse s'échapper alors que tu
es toujours mieux mais que bon voilà les
quatre seront combinés on sait pas c'est
ça le truc c'est qu'il force à prendre
un choix responsable serre que là et ça
c'est le maximum à me l'avait expliqué
en plus dans ces sessions de blitz qu'il
aimait bien ses coups y avait une prise
en passant c'est parce que ce soit tu le
fais maintenant soit tu le fais jamais
il me disait pas du coup quand je peux
avancer d'une case ou deux noms blitz
soit dit avance de deux cases comme ça
d'un coup le mec va tu le met sous
pression
je peins le choix doit être pris en fait
tu prends ou tu prends pas et là c'est
vrai qu'il refait ce h5
il a 12 minutes il le voit il envoie
bien tu as aimé comme tu dis un pion
prend d'un premier fils en plus t'as vu
tour g1 j'ai vu les vannes après ce coup
là ouais ça al'air catastrophique après
tour f1 mais c'est pas si simple
non il faut bien l'évaluer puisque le
premier sentiment le premier coup qui
vient à l'esprit c'est grâce à ses 25
ans et là ça devient très chaud et si tu
prends pas et tu avais tu dois aussi
qu'alors que c'est sûr ça va alors voilà
est ce que je fais fausse et 5h un jeu
trop croisée qu'est ce qui nous dit
journée ça marche en fait furieusement
ils ont fou des quatre prochains mois sa
plus n'ont pas la chance ça marche comme
prévu a du coup là il ya peut-être une
idée parce que ça c'est quand même le
plus tentants pour les blancs moi c'est
ce que je ferais personnes maintenant
premier là tu calcules comme un fouet
mais ces choses-là pendulaires portillon
et un coup il ya fait dame de l'abbaye
par son sacrifice
ok parfait voir alors dix tours c5 et si
je fais tout rage
c'est le premier truc que tu calcules
qu'il prendrait 5 qui avait prend des
cinq tours prend des cinq tours pour h
sauf sam suivent tour pro high shifter
progrès mais est-ce que ça fait peur 3
j'ai vu aussi je peux pas voir
genre comme ça de ouf bouge à damas
ouais mais je veux essayer un truc
pareil au juste pour montrer un bien
joli mais bon même ça ça tu sors pas en
fait
bon malgré tout par pour essayer de
mater je sais pas peut-être qu'il ya une
porte de sortie mais malheureusement il
ya beaucoup de tombes choc selon ses
standards c'est que 9 minutes 30 mai en
ce moment là ils jouent sur ces trente
secondes ici en fait hors france et 3
maintenant ailleurs cinq y arrive pas il
faut prendre 5 janvier le cavaliere f k
tu tiens tu la joues un peu mais là non
là c'est trop donc ça ça va pas non plus
mon fab monaco 1 2 et 10 heures tour ses
cinq tours à chaque dame à 6 et qui
avait cinq heures c'est sûrement une
connerie c'est bon écoute l'ordi read et
adam eve 3 4 me qui lisse la guitare je
vais être une rente en fait pour voir un
juge trop comprendre aux américaines
s'arrête là ok donc à temps les deux
dames assises c'est sur ces cinq tours à
chasser le coup de plus logique de base
mais qui pas du tout entreprendre new
way et il y à damas six auxquelles
shifter pro
ouais en fait peut être une bonne
nouvelle c'est que faut pas faire
tourache un métrage 3 qui est du même
niveau en termes d'idées et que tu tiens
mieux des 5
ok mais qu'elle prendrait cinq jours et
je veux qu a laissé trois tours dé
rejeter l'imint à tour les amuse-bouches
machin tu fais quoi là bas je bouge ton
cheval
ouais non h un jeu trucs basiques
j'ai pas le temps de tubes à d'autres
acheteurs profitent à reconstruire
5 c'est terrible mais peut-être tu peux
prendre cette firme en h1 en d1 je veux
dire bah tu me fais reconstruction prend
2 me prends pour des jeux parce qu'il me
fait l'a dit c'est du copier coller la
souris qui bouge tout seul match du tour
ces cinq voiliers du tour c'est 5
maintenant je l'aï fait souvent regretté
surtout rage 3 qui est des cinq epr en
france voire achat pour des deux camps
c'est une ford a maintenant tu vois
autoritaire peut être un piège sa jolie
déviation déviation pour prendre un
homme prend 2 comprend des huit pioches
ou dommages
il faut trouver faut être encore j'ai à
chaque fois trois bandes-annonces hockey
à temps mais ça ça veut tout beau
tourner je sais pas ça ça peut passer
comme siège
moi j'ai encore un peu d'espoir on est
pas on n'est pas confiant confiant mais
non mais là il fait là maintenant il
filme on sait tous très bien joué h5
bien joué non c'est 5 vient jouer la
série joue pas refuser beaucoup
progresser frustrant c'est que c'est
tous les jours tu as deux trois coups à
côté et tout le reste c'est super tu
aurais passé deux coups mais vraiment
des coups bizarre en plus
après c'est à des positions difficiles
mais tu ci joue à ce niveau là après le
cavaly g4 bas du cou t'imagines le jeu
me tendant votants bah oui fait cai est
gâté il joue à ce niveau là il gagne
quoi juste alors peut-être ai-je
principaux tenter ce piège qu'il avait
avec damas six dans le zoo car dans le
sud oui mais toi je pense qu'il va bien
de jouer la suite là tu imagines fait on
prend cinq tours 2 1 comme on chante tu
vas ligne comment les chapelco mon
écharpe et un coup du tout est joué tour
h3 bon bah c'est la vente qu'on a vu un
rôle demain si c'est tout il va y avoir
le dares ci souhaite il peut le rater ou
pas à greccio tu peux mais peut-être
six maintenant peut-être damas six
maintenant en falloir dame insiste
maintenant donc eu à pâtir prince 51.2
damage de et le coup detat envie de
faire qui les prend des 5 cm attendant
mais ça c'est bon ouais stratégiquement
l'opposition on dirait truc cavagnan f4
tenir h 5 mois peut-être déjà fait
qu'elle prend des cinq mois c'est ce
qu'on aurait joué aussi à s'élever bon
il a vu le piège qu'on a vus par on a vu
l'envié a vu emprise frise tour h1 d'un
v6 ça c'est sûr et on va prier pour ton
france 5 france ce serait beau top 5 des
6 400 kw et ses 4 c'est sale coup ça
fait mal ford et dodge nitro h 5 min 35
maintenant j'ai acheté mon tour d un
tour prend d un oui au regard des 1
pouces et twitter mais avant c'était pas
bien aidé à me six autres pas perdu mais
ce que tu as in the rain on s'est un peu
pareil quoi je pensais dam des cinq six
sept finales là c'est de plus en plus
pour les plans c'est ça c'est que c'est
quand même bien oui ça va devenir de
très vite et à cinq ans alors ça c'est
abandon case ih oui oui bon coup droit
bon est-ce que gris
peut se tromper je vais le mettre dans
grand écran j'ai du mal à croire qu est
prise des cinq prises des 5 s'est jouée
au portier entourent h1 c'est sur ce
crash un vrai c'est 100% sur leur donne
ainsi un regard y réfléchit il hésite je
peux trouver pour achat à les dames à 6
maxime tempo je pense à lui sortir dans
no 6 ouais bah les fab
à moins qu'il ya un autre truc de
marloux ailleurs que assistons à une
dame assise parce que je suis un peu
stressée là à ce même dame des 600 fait
que si je prends tous âges 5 tu
attendais un chèque et tu fais tout
échanger un coursier d'amd s'ils
souhaitent être est ce que il faut quand
même en parler de ça lors d un 5 sur le
marché
chapeau et tu t'en mets
changeons ok mais ça ça peut être pas
mal ça c'est dur avoir tardé si ça peut
être le coup et surtout reprend h5
direct tour d'air 3 2 ghz et un tutorat
je crois assez dur bah c'est vrai c'est
fort on va tu vois tu dis même joli joli
tout ça je trouve ça bête ou quoi
et je pense va plutôt tenter samax ah je
pensais plusieurs que l'autre qui est
criante et encore tous rangs quand même
y'a pas à y as tu veux faire [ __ ]
d'amd 1,28 ça me prenait un tour prend
des uns avaient peut-être cette finale
encore prend 1,5
sarkozy option - attache 5 bientôt 2 on
n'est pas bon mais bon procès pas on
peut toujours trouver des trucs email et
fossés cinq tours h5 tour des deux
manifs en avait deux ces problèmes on
perd dans mon projet de jeu souvent à
quoi cette abandonne pas tout de suite
tout de suite non non non tu va la
perdre mais la marche 3 la maj frat-mat
quand damas trois noms iv robien et
verra bien et vous info chat 1 et donc
dam des six est plus résistant mémoire
ce que la grande
pendant cinq tours d un roi est là et ça
t'en faut le voir tout rage 3 quand même
je suis dit moi marlou métrages trois
fautes vivons entourage crois-tu peu
raté un truc je sais pas oui parce que
tourner plusieurs coups ribera fois çi
ce qui marche en cinquième fois en six
mois les dommages 500 oui mais géré ça
m'embête un cookie fatah comme une
ribambelle de coûts qui pourraient
marcher je vais avec des touches de
saint-amand confiant j'ai jamais joué
aussi vite tu bluffes martonyi non mais
bluff il joue vite envahi sort sa grosse
partie d'un jeu dit le message de vote
s'étaient pas encourageant tu vas voir
infliger cette hausse qui peut récupérer
marché mais tous ne touche pas un machin
il faut six élèves d'apprendre ça vous
prend 1,5 mais tu as enfin non et bien
sûr il ya un qui marche mais en partie
tu peux avoir peur en pratique un jeu
je trouve qu'il joue très vite et rendre
un vent de compliquer rapidement passant
il aurait pu faire des trucs avant je
sais pas c'est ça qui me fait dire qui
est très confiant et d'amd si story 6
échecs satour premier achat même g4 en
dribblant c'est pour essayer de winnie
19 août shot nom d'un guerrier a gagné
un faux et il n'ya rien précieux dans 15
des grègues votre neuf coups sûrs et
brewery il écoute moi relancer grave
dans la course un demi point de dépôt
demain il faut gagner ce qu'elles ont à
mettre en ligne contre lui donc
c'est possible bref 0 à voir on va voir
ce que max jouets dam des six dames à 6
clairement la menace des blancs store
princes 5 comprend dame prend pour aller
mater le roi voilà il faut tout ouvrir
et il y aller à fond
donc faut réagir avec énergie à côte
énorme pas se laisser marcher dessus
highgy impressionnant comment il a gagné
en faisant 3 harvin contre ding il a
défoncé la chine en ce temps des agents
doubles bing entre eux qui veulent pas
trop mal bah oui oui même très bien
alors on en avait fait une bonne partie
maxime très bien joué bien raté mais bon
c'est parce qu'il était bien à partir on
sait pas si c'est évident de faire nul
ou est finalement là le la phase retour
la deûle annonce à +1 +2 gilding il va
être content de faire à 50% faille ce si
difficile à moins encore se fait
dézinguer après il a vraiment raté
maxime mais bon donc c'est son problème
c'est son problème à lui
ouais
dames d'essayer d'investissement si
j'arrive à les voir les tours h3c make
way
mais le truc le plus dur pour le tour h3
je trouve si celui-là - prise d'abord et
la torah transposition c'est beaucoup
alors pourquoi
jordan brand ça a l'air d'être réglé il
ya tour ici et chaque cours et qui va
échanger la tour recevra disons en
échange la décision est ok bon du coup
il ya plus de matches possibles c'est
l'heure de vérité
mesqui claquant h56 fait tampon f5 sait
qu'il a tout vu
d'après la turbine roi de marche aussi
si l autre au logis où vous en faites
vous
enfin si votre âge très va tout faire si
tu rates tour h3 tu sues il y aura deux
femmes bas peut-être enfin je sais pas
quoi dire
peut-être que toi je sais pas il le rate
baros co pourquoi trois ont bien montré
vente comme il le rate fab qui croient
ou qui croient pas maxime il a la baraka
sur ses candidats
il devait pas y être il y est phase
aller il a quand même pas mal de
réussite fab
c'est un peu bresse +2 c'est vraiment la
réussite maximum qu'ils pouvaient avoir
il a cette réussite il est bien phase
retour jusqu'à maintenant
la réussite est vraiment des perruques
pour il a vraiment beaucoup de réussite
pas de retour il est chaud dit qu'il
devait déjà s'incliner il a sauvé un
truc insauvable il a la baraka la baraka
continue fab la baraka continue pour le
français à la france il a vraiment l'air
dehors blé peut-être un mur de barbelés
c'est le moment s'il ya bien un envoi de
les bars blessée la dame attend j'ai
rarement vu quelqu'un furent un tournant
avoir autant de chances que honnêtement
c'est le gars le plus chanceux du
tournoi la faune ce fait le candidat le
plus chanceux de l'histoire du jour
n'est candidat je vois pas pourquoi ça
s'arrêterait maintenant autant être à
jamais la vie tu as déjà vu un mec aussi
chanteur et candidat ben moi je ne
m'appelle pas déjà je rappelle pas d'un
gars skient je joue sans être qualifié
non non il a la baraka maxime gris
tchoucrav courage 3 et ça va continuer
ça va tu iras tourache autres communes
carrément à mais il va la gagner c'est
gagné et oui le rituel dans le ton de
plus imaginez la gagne l'homme le plus
chanceux du monde quoi mvl
rien il l'a pas il l'a pas fait roi de
il a pas il l'a pas fabre il panique il
serait ce là je connais mon sasha mais
hors wad autour des 1 en fait comme
trouver un coup droit je le connais très
bien sa charge
bon c'est toujours un bon cours de ce
retour d'un et quand même 3 5 mais la
tour d enfer tempo la maxime va
réfléchir la faille aller taper le choix
tu dois les igloos et les pièces si tu
attaques sur la colonne h s'est pas fait
les gains autour d un peu calme de faire
35 tours h3 et c'est la même position
parce qu'on avait du temps mais bon
c'est dur à faire voilà il va faire ça
pour lui si la dame derrière
ouais alors je comprends pas alors diddy
tour des quatre îles sur d'imagés
géantes emprunt car tu sais quoi dire je
veux faire trop prompts à quatre c'est
magnifique comprendre d'un v6 wouah ça
peut se finir comme ça on s'en viennent
va déjà fonds sursaut d'un demi point
je sais que ça peut vraiment y lire
comme ça ça oui parce qu'en vrai la
variante autour des 1 prise prise prises
pour faire d'un majeur est quand même
assez logique parce que sur tours d2 il
ya dans le cadre d'un match cette fête
s'arrête ça la partie c'est ça le plus
logique
ouais et maxime il va l'avoir tour des 4
bat façon à laisser ta plus chaud mais
c'est sûr qu'il va le voir bon écoute on
peut souhaiter cela fait tour des quatre
c'est sur le coup puisque damage de
tours prend 1,4 c'est le seul coup oui
c'est sûr il va sauver la nulle c'est
sûr que ça va être ça les gars olalalala
à ce sauvetage des enfers battant défi
notion son entourage qu on a perdu
oui mais on va pas prendre courage 3
mais n'est ce pas moi je crois au tour 5
toi aussi
c'est logique way et si macky sall tour
des cats a sauvé il va prendre garde il
touche le pion max
mme hilal tour des quatre garçons
sourire de marloux regarde le il a le
tour des quatre il a le tour des quatre
il va faire ton prof 5
il va faire ton courage cinquième axe il
a le tour des quatre fabil là bas il
peut enfin je sais pas pourquoi pas un
petit peu il c'est un truc qui peut
avoir il peut avoir je suis dit mon côté
j'ai pas du bon côté jean sa peau le
drapeau me rassure je suis un drapeau
femmes prendre au jeu de drapé
je te rappelle je suis un drapeau là
j'ai pas comment le maître méchant
drapeau [ __ ] j'ai peur il l'a et yuki
panique et max il là je le connais mon
marlou je le connaisse horaires de
marloux fab il là oui il l'a dit lui un
fab tempo tout autour des 4 mais oui
femmes
mais oui mais oui mon marlou mais oui je
te fais un jeu tap la mapar ouais je te
tape la main par le plexiglas il là il
là les amis et tous les défaitistes dans
le chat qui vont fermer leurs gueules
maman tab
il a je suis content là je me lave à 10
ou 20%
il a eu un tas il a sauvé c'était sûr
c'est le marlou désolent les amis il
reste en vie il reste en vie maxime il
reste en vie et toulouse au regard rivé
les la selle et là cela c'est qu'ils
tombent les amis
le requin et la famille bien nager un
peu de ton côté il revient là le marlou
des andes
il est là mon maxi regarder les comptes
ans il est content il a fini par craquer
de roscoff
c'était sur les a mis un an et demi
qu'il a pas gagné et c'est pas
aujourd'hui qui gagnera les amis
c'est pas aujourd'hui fab et voilà il se
lève mais aucun marchand plus on analyse
une fantastique les amis à y en avait un
nombre de loser dans le chatt là j'en
pouvais plus à ça va commencer à fermer
sa bouche là haut ça fait plaisir
ladoire un maxime l'acquis qui envoie du
très lourd et ça repart marché
c'est terrible non mais t'as bien
calculé comme tel monstre qu'elle mons
quel piège mais tu vois il l'aurait ce
niveau là tout le long de la partie il
est injouable
c'est le meilleur joueur du monde mais
il fait des beaux débats ont donné rue
sur 99% des coups c'est le meilleur
joueur du monde et nous fait une merde
de temps en temps il peut encore aller
chercher ces candidats femmes les jo qui
sut ça fait plaisir la femme ça fait
plaisir ça s'est passé quelque chose qui
peut tuer à être choc complètement
vouloir absolument gagner oui je sais
pas quel coup mais oui et oui j'ai envie
de te dire il peut il peut faire il peut
faire
tiens la chine y aura pas assez
incroyable regarde un petit peu c'est
vraiment le prédateur quoi qui rôdent
autour de sa proie maintenant il reste
en vie dans ce tournoi j'ai envie de
décrire un tweet quoi mv elle est
magique
carmat ouais
foot locker licorne bien sûr
mais bien sûr les amis on ne pense
trop de choix de forme d'hommage de
youtube et il voit le problème
mais quoi faire extraordinaire femmes
c'est extraordinaire ce qui vient de
faire il reste en vie dans ce tournoi et
demain à l'iccn copine le point bima
l'excès enhco dans ta tronche mais ce
soir ça vous prend des quatre bains je
pense y à damas trois échecs et tour
quand des cadres et du coup tu as plutôt
d'un match 2 parce que m'attendais à un
match bon du coup tu suis un peu comme
ainsi complètement là bas je crois qu'il
doit faire damage de farnell ouais je
pense que plus tu es mal autant tu sais
que tu fais autre chose tu vas perdre
dans les vases il va fermer a permet
mais pas d'autre choix
diarra issue complexe
sacha il a fait une grosse partie et oui
mais pas assez grosse non à la tht a
l'impression de jouer une attaque contre
un ordi fait ça doit marcher
will meet you contre le meilleur joueur
du monde de marche voilà maintenant ce
cas de figure la maxime est le mien
aujourd'hui oui tu te prends j'ai pas
assez fort battant il a vraiment 30
secondes ou ouais non il va il va
peut-être la perle et à epagny qui
panique vous avez tout le travail il va
il va jouer les gains il est
complètement fou maxime balcon très tôt
à agen waouh au québec tout reprend 1,4
m
si on prend d'amd 5 et d'un proche à le
faire revient du coup complètement fou
je sais pas ce que ça ni complètement
taré grille tout cas enfin faut qu'il
arrête il est complètement fou j'vas
leur 10ème tour h4 mais en 3 h 4 dante
un double final et tu vas finale non
plus n'ont peut-être un moyen de ces
journées vous passion ok bon sens vers
enfin on est moins inquiet va peut-être
qu'on peut gagner on peut perdre tout
peut arriver mais on ne vendait plus
matois khalid magicien c'est maxime boy
mais là on est loin de perdre en fait
j'avais pu c'est pas seul coup je crois
que il mais quand même c'est que surfer
tour d un il va voir demain il va avoir
attendu son pion h5 ballet fut sa joue
le beau jeu complètement foutraque mais
bon en fait on attendra un peu moins de
bucquoy excuses on avait le tweet est
très heureux quoi toujours
qu'ils m'envoient oui il a toujours su
bokova qui est tout le temps sur les
tweets par lettres dorées sur les
structures est il ya pas un monde où tu
fais md5 damage 5 tu prends un petit à 4
tu donnes ta ptite dame
deux tours j'ai pu donner plus de voix
la fable là le stress est trop présent
je pense que la finale tour à 424 séparé
des trucs bio j attends prend 1,4 puis
on prend pas possible il ya la double
attaque
ça serait l'embellie évidemment et pour
provoquer à tout et on croit bien il se
dit vue de faire d'un match 2 ou damage
5 est matée mais du coup lui remets la
tour la barre et du coup la plus la dame
devant et on lui échange je pense ça et
c'est quasiment forcé à venir ici après
peut-être tour gère un secteur pranger
5e j'aurais fait ça je pense qu'on s'en
aller mais je sais pas où on va les mecs
sont complètement fous contre maxime l'a
aimée il trop fort un léger redoux qui
vous tous rachats ou comme ding qui a
joué 24 heures le truc de malade
à défaut ce droit de faire nul les gars
quoi va non mais je pense qu'ils sont
trop énervés de se faire arnaquer et du
coup il perdre toute lucidité parce que
ça n'arrive jamais à personne au monde à
part maxime capable de faire ça mais ça
veut dire qu'on reste bien dans les
candidats en réalité la seule inquiétude
on devrait de cette journée il ya une
victoire de geek i
ce qui est pénible quand même ce que ça
veut dire que caruana il va envoyer au
lean contre lui qui gagne 20 du coup
c'est caruana qui est pénible sur ce qui
signifie contre guy est plus que pénible
puisque annuler la séance d'hier
oui tout cas c'est chaud moi je pense
qu'il va jouer la position avec los dos
dames
je sais pas fab
en tout cas c'est incroyable ce qui
sauve ans est prêté importe quoi de
faire ça mais ça donne des chances de
gain dans ce cas là il a un petit peu
retrouvé son jeu là c'est peut-être là
il a vraiment très bien joué il avait
pas si bien joué que ça dans les autres
défense non mais conquis ronaldo début
de partie était bien là mais là il a
vraiment été impressionnant quand même
ça peut le faire
mon fab petit peu
fait quand c'est que du calcul il est
très bien moi j'ai envie de te dire
qu'il peut arrêter maxime sûrement pas
la 4g quand c'est que du calcul il qui
sait calculer pas lui enlever à une
incroyable maxime allais ça peut le
faire
cette tour prend 1,4 seul coup et plus
ou moins mais c'est plus logique pas le
seul mais le plus logique non maîtrise
de dames mais c'est ça c'est ça qui
réfléchit maxime que je viens de faire
en commençant par tour prend 1,4 any way
en fait mais je sens qu'il peut être la
5g peut l'arrêter
habuba il est pas sur son album il y la
4g non l'arête lesquels j'ai nommé à
cinq j'ai peut-être n'ont-ils pas son
nom avec singly pense qu'ils arrêtent
ouais mais maintenant c'est très dur 4g
ça va il gère mes 5 j'ai peut-être ça
l'art est peut-être mais c'est pas sûr
non plus bas froid plus tôt que sylvain
riss ici la fin du morceau de la chanson
5 j y suis un monsieur parce que à la
fin du morceau 4g ce qui est mort six
appels 4g
il est 13h et qui peut m'arrêter pas la
4g ça ça va t'en prends à 4 dans la fin
du morceau 5g et u à ifs l'entourage
quatrième des cinq tours h4h 4 paraît
plus logique de ouf
mais s'il veut jouer bien il va claquer
la dame sur la toile bien faire tour h4
c'est trop grave espère peut-être la
chance incroyable qui met l'autre en
sueur je sais pas 20 euros 3,4 tu fais
nul succès c'est bon dmd 5 tu te mets un
bon sueur pour un tour g4 ouais mais
c'est pas qu'on se fait attaquer combat
d'ici je vois pas pourquoi on est mal en
fait je vais montrer un pourrait-on pas